peu
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais que ce soit et marchent arrive
le camion
le jeu attractif
comme à gauche
o sweeney
je suis
il y en a plus
si notre hyde
gelli
[Applaudissements]
le bar dieu
julie leblanc dieu
phil schiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si mal
ml non 28
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
ouais si omar sharif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a recherché le prince ali de lawrence
d'arabie
si vous fait quoi quand vous écouter
cette musique là
ça ça m'énerve montpellier tuellement
entendu a plus ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle ma jeunesse que je cherche à
oublier absolument alors maintenant on
en même temps omar lawrence d'arabie
c'est le film qui marque vos débuts de
comédien internationale en 1962 et qui
fera de vous la première et la seule
star arabe d'hollywood
c'était du temps de nasser
oui ça veut dire c'est comme si
aujourd'hui quelqu'un du pays de saddam
hussein dont canirac allaient devenir
les relations entre les états unis et
nasser est pas terrible alors après et
lawrence d'arabie il ya eu docteur
jivago marco polo meilleures lignes vous
avez incarné gengis khan che guevara
nicolas 2 alors aucun nouveau film ne
vous satisfait vraiment avec vous
déclarez vous dit
finalement dix secondes dans un film 10
secondes dans un autre mais globalement
il a aucun qui vous plaît vraiment il ya
des films qui me plaisent mais ils
veulent me plaît pas moi même je veux
dire par exemple j'adore lawrence
d'arabie
mais je trouve que j'aurais pu faire
mieux art est d'accord alors ça vous a
pas empêché d'être récompensé au
festival du film de venise
puisqu'on vous a décerné un lion d'or
pour l'ensemble de votre carrière donc
pour tous ces films et que vous avez pas
tellement ça recommence à hollywood à
l'american film institute pareil encore
une récompense un email pour dire ça
sent le sapin
oui exactement c'est bon c'est bien déjà
ne pas les recevoir de façon posthume à
voir de son vivant mais il faut arriver
à mon âge pour arriver à voir ces prix
là il faut avoir 71 ans et avoir tourné
50 ans cette année le 50e anniversaire
de mon premier film voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors j'aimerais qu'on voit un peu votre
histoire dont vous êtes né à alexandrie
oui voilà d'une famille de commerçants
aisés j'étais dans le bois d'origine
libanaise syro-libanaise siro les cires
les bains de saillon crécy valin des
pigeons les interfaces alors vous êtes
fils unique votre père voulait que vous
preniez sa succession mais vous avez
refusé et un jour dans un salon de thé
vous rencontrez youssef chahine
exactement grands réalisateurs et vous
faites en 53 votre premier film ciel
d'enfer qui fait de vous immédiatement
une star en egypte le film est
sélectionné au festival de cannes en
1954 et là bas vous dites j'ai été
accueilli comme un sex symbol parlant il
sera si homosexuels c'est vrai je lis si
je les issues très tard dans ma vie par
un copain moi qui était prévu qui est
mort cette année l'année passée je crois
qu'ils étaient si vous voulez le le
président général leroy un des
homosexuels de france et qui est l
autorité absolue sur tout ce qui se
passait en propre ce qui est rejeté à
monsieur qui s'appelait andré manu ce
qui était un homme très riche et très
longtemps non mais je dis sans nom
j'exerce y est parce que d'un homme
célèbre vraiment il était un homme
exquis d'ailleurs donc monsieur manuce
vous des crêtes sex-symbol voilà il
averti la france entière qui a une bombe
atomique qui arrivent des chips a alors
j'ai eu cocteau comme président du jury
j'ai vu philippe erlanger qui nous est
membre du jury
oui alors une souricière pour tous
il y avait du monde j'ai pas vu un prix
que tout ça non pas un prénom
j'ai failli alors à ce moment là donc
vous devenez aussi en france où l'on
s'intéresse énormément avoue et pas
seulement l'aristocratie homosexuels
comme vous dites mais fait la une de
signer monde et et vous refusez alors ça
c'est incroyable refuser un script un
claude chabrol
écoutez j'ai fait beaucoup de mauvais
films on m'a même énormément de mauvais
goût et mais je n'ai jamais voulu faire
un mauvais film en le sachant que j'ai
trouvé avec un grand metteur en scène
ça me semblait dans un tel gâchis alors
c'est à l'époque comme art que vous
rencontrez faten hamama qu'est la star
absolue à l'école de ma main non à ma
mère que pour beaucoup de français mais
tant qu'ils veulent star absolue c'est
maître capello qui est en moi la star
absolue donc du cinéma arabe mais qui
est marié oui ça fait un scandale ça
fait mouche a fait scandale
et puis on est tombé amoureux quoi je
vais rien à faire avait rien à faire là
bas où j'avais 21 ans 1
et donc elle a divorcé oui et moi j'ai
embrassé l'islam
alors oui parce que venger il faut dire
d'abord c'est que c'est pas votre vrai
nom évidemment omar sharif votre vrai
nom c'est michel chalhoub et d'ailleurs
certains films où vous apparaissez sous
le nom de omar el sharif
c'est ça au début je m'appelle je
m'appelle omar el sharif firme on passe
pas un mais mais pour le pour les films
américains et marché français jean marc
cherry omar m'a tuer sur un générique
oui
avec un air et donc changé de nom et
vous convertir effectivement à la
religion musulmane
oui aujourd'hui que vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit par rapport à ça moi je
suis en réalité je suis tolérant je suis
agnostique
ouais donc je ne crois pas mais j'ai le
doute je ne suis pas certain je n'ai
aucune certitude d'ailleurs non dans la
vie je suis prêt à douter de tout alors
votre premier film omar sur les écrans
occidentaux c'est la châtelaine du liban
et en 62 après laurence vous signez un
contrat de sept ans avec columbia et là
vous arrivez à hollywood alors salut est
pour vous c'est là l'essentiel c'est
bien les avec les terrifiantes parce que
vous avez arrivent à hollywood en 62 1
donc j'arrive du caire à hollywood
directement 62 c'était la révolution
culturelle est là et c'était surtout la
révolution le mlf mouvement libération
de la femme
alors c'était en 62 qu'elles ont enlevé
tous les soutiens-gorge et qu'il ya eu
les discothèques
je suis arrivé en même temps que les
beatles et les rolling stones chaîne
tout cette décennie cette décennie
exercice bien sûr c'est celui connu et
alors que c'était pour moi c'était
arrivé à sodome et gomorrhe alors que
j'arrivais du caire ou plutôt comment
chadha est comme un gamin
les femmes que j'avais jusque là en
egypte où les femmes étaient traîtres
stresa très couverte contre flop n'est
pas bon se tenait à peine la main quand
on avait une petite amie mais alors là
d'un coup là tout le monde était
pratiquement à quoi l'on sait ça oui ou
non ils étaient calmes et tout le monde
j'ai fait si chaud en egypte y en a
aussi non il ya un beau coup non mais je
veux dire la base c'était c'était plutôt
la coquelles et les drogues plus à
l'époque c'était la mode l'aed a cru
bien et alors là vous sentez que vous
allez craquer et vous dit rien faten
hamama votre femme enfin madame sharif à
l'époque
séparons nous avant que je te trompes
oui c'est extraordinaire ce nom ça veut
dire que je sentais la tentation rien
n'avait pas vu tout ça donc voie pour
une fois j'ai commencé à ressentir
vraiment une envie forte de tromper ma
femme
bon je veux jouer au petit jeu c'est le
nom en plus alors que chez nous donc à
l'époque on pensait que les flammes à
partir de 40 ans j'étais des vieilles
qui pourraient plus trouver un homme
ouais alors j'ai eu peur comme elle
avait deux enfants
elle allège pour nous autres pour une
starlette quelconque et qu'elle n'est
plus l'opportunité de refaire sa vie
avec un homme
donc j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux
c'est vachement devrait venir
c'est pas lâchement bien ceci parce que
toute façon vous l'auriez tromper vous
le savez et là vous dites plutôt que la
garder avec moi je la possibilité de
refaire ses elle a refait sa vie faten
hamama très bien alors en cette chose
qui ait eu raison et cela dit moi je ne
suis plus tombé amoureux de personnes
bah oui c'est ça sire que vous dites
depuis j'ai beaucoup baiser non c'est ça
l'islam
non vraiment pas j'ai d'ailleurs pas
beaucoup baiser s'assèche l'homme tu
peux composer beaucoup moins que to make
up
oui c'est ce que vous même temps sud non
mais c'est vrai que j'ai le nombre de
coups tirés mais c'est vrai vous dites
j'ai jamais aimé une autre femme et j'ai
jamais vécu avec une autre femme même
pas une semaine
moi j'ai besoin d'être amoureux pour
vivre avec quatre canadiens pas vivre
avec quelqu'un dont je ne suis pas
amoureux mais ce qu'il ya c'est que moi
je voyage est tout le temps je suis le
seul acteur au monde qui n'est pas qui
je suis étranger partout ouais donc
j'avais ma valise et j'allais dans des
hôtels et si une femme avait voulu me
suivre et vivre avec moi hein je ne
l'aurais pas aimer parce que j'aurais
été une femme qui ne travaillait pas
exploser quelque chose de s'occuper de
moi je n'aime pas les femmes servent ils
j'aime plutôt me back de disputer avec
quelques à brec'h par des arguments des
arguments non mais c'est vrai qu'on vous
prête des aventures avec les plus belles
femmes du nom mais c'est parce que
j'étais célibataire et que on pouvait
dire quand je vois que je sortais avec
quelqu'un peut être dire et chanter
ensemble voilà puisqu'il est libre
on dit que les hommes mariés c'est plus
délicat on les voit avec quelqu'un
d'autre on mange pas vraiment écrire
dans le journal que ils ont une aventure
alors je dis les plus belles femmes du
monde
il ya barbra streisand c'est pas la plus
belle femme du monde d'ailleurs la
première fois que vous l'avez vu vous ce
que vous appelez votre argent je n'ai
pas tourné avec elle et les scènes
d'amour
jennifer a tourné des scènes je veux pas
lui dire tu m as roma alors anita ekberg
c'est vrai ça qu'en maintenant écoutez
il ya une condition que j'ai pautrat et
peut être avec une femme j'ai besoin de
ne pas me mettre sur la pointe des pieds
pour l'embrasser et j'ai besoin de
pouvoir que mes mains se joignit
derrière son dos c'était un peu un essai
pas pression' faire comme ça aussi
aller à d'autres je vais pas faire fi de
la vistule enfin disons yanouk aimé oui
oui j'ai une amitié amoureuse j'ai eu d
amitié amour et evelyne dhéliat livia
qui la pécho pas maintenant sophie
davant
non non je balance par aucun mât était
donc vous avez déclaré effectivement
quand j'ai quitté l'egypte pour faire ma
carrière internationale j'avais un bel
appartement une belle femme
un gosse que j'adorais et depuis j'ai
vécu seul d'hôtel en hôtel avec une
valise
or quand même ça va inviter dans l'hôtel
l'hiver est au sheraton du caire
c'est ça en général java juin septembre
royal monceau à paris
camping voilà le camping non mais alors
c'est très marrant d'ailleurs parce que
au royal monceau
vous ouvrez jamais les rideaux ou sais
même pas si la fenêtre sur la rue nous
si on a un goût sûr la cour parce que
vous dites j'ai vu tout c'est terrible
ça j'ai vu tous les paysages et la seule
chose dont j'ai besoin maintenant ce
sont des visages
oui c'est vrai j'aime j'aime les gens
j'aime j'aime quand je vais dans un pays
que je ne connais pas j'aime connaître
les gens et les ti vous êtes à deauville
au royal barrière au royal sera quand
même très bien ah bah oui c'est super
mais le luxe est pas tout moi je veux
dire les grands hôtels tout ça c'est pas
tout il faut du coup ce soir un endroit
vous n'êtes pas de romance et pas de
maison d'un poignet j'ai pas d'objets
par exemple et aucun objet c'est marrant
j'ai pas par exemple je peux pas
transporter mes livres d'hôtel en hôtel
n'est pas de livre j'ai pas de disque se
vend excusez moi un petit peu comme un
travailleur et oui anoman alors c'était
une maison 3 pas quand même
vous êtes devenu disons joueurs par
ennui justement par misanthropie vous
dites pour occuper le temps en fait
c'est dire que vous êtes seul le soir
dans une chambre de bâle
vous préférez aller dans un casino paris
le 10 juin
on peut dîner seul c'est le seul endroit
on n'est pas ridicule quand on va
seulement
merci on est un acteur qu'on a on va
dans un restaurant tout seul et on
commande un repas on est ridicule on se
sent ridicule comme ça dit qu'un casino
on peut aller tout seul
le jour où tu en vises solitaire il
effectue lui mais seul mais je ne suis
pas passionné par le jeu je peux m'en
passer
si j'ai un rendez-vous à dîner ou si
j'ai une petite amie par exemple par
hasard eh bien je ne pense pas du tout
aller jouer tout le monde croit que vous
êtes accro je te sera pas du tout gênée
je n'aime pas sa pratique
c'est le dernier j'ai la dernière chose
qui me reste un an je n'ai rien de mieux
à faire
le plus grosses pertes c'est en 78 palm
beach 80 millions de francs d'une soirée
non j'ai perdu j'ai perdu pour des
grosses sommes mais j'ai une fois j'ai
gagné et plusieurs fois j'ai perdu mais
moi j la sortie s'en sortir plus value
plus perdu c'est ça qui est un prix
beaucoup plus perdu jungle a perdu
troublant de l'argent que je gagne je le
perds mais parce que j'ai une
particularité c'est que quand j'ai de
l'argent je suis obligé de le dépenser
j'ai vraiment je n'arrive pas à garder
l'argent les poches percées commander
mais ça ne me gêne pas de ne pas en
avoir par contre je vis aussi
heureusement quand je n'en ai pas je
change de restaurants c'est donc de
l'avant lors des brasseries comment au
juste payer l'hôtel avant je paie pas
l'automne je ne vais pas d'hôtel moi
c'est pour ça que je peux me permettre
aux non mais sinon vous pourriez vous
auriez cru que j'étais riche si je
vivais au royal monceau a percé bêtement
que c'était payant
je suis l'invité un propriétaire la
royal monceau est un jeu très très bien
que si rien qui m'aiment bien à d'accord
j'ai moi aussi beaucoup la syrie
démocratique les gens sont très heureux
non mais elle savait perdu une fois ci
c'est vrai au casino l'appartement vous
possédiez à paris c'est vrai ça veut
dire j'ai dû vendre mon appart ans pour
payer mes dettes de jeux et autres là
d'accord j'avais c'est la seule fois où
j'ai eu un appartement 1 et sesat 1 du
refi l'année voilà ça a duré quatre cinq
ans mais qu'on aimerait bien il va vous
appeler votre agent lendemain matin il
on trouve moi un film n'importe quelle
guerre d' ce que tu veux
demain mais le vaucluse à demain demain
voilà fallait que ça demain j'avais
toujours un film de retard d'ailleurs
que je chaque film fut tourné c'était
pour payer les dettes de l avait déjà un
peu comme darry cowl à la brute il ya
des gens et jean lefebvre jean le jeu
vous êtes obligés de faire de la pub
pour tiercé magazine
oui je le fais encore ouais je vous ai
vu l'autre jour et c'est bien parce que
c'est ça me fais moi j'ai toujours eu
envie d'avoir un salaire moyen d'avoir
une rentrée netflix est chaque mois
voilà parce que le problème de l'acteur
c'est que chaque fois qu'on tourne un
film on sait pas quand est ce qu'on va
tourner un autre alors que le fait
d'avoir une rentrée sur ça me rassure ça
mais ça me fait plaisir et ça fait
beaucoup de gens alors dites moi il
s'est passé quoi au casino d'enghien le
5 juillet là nous a mis un coup de boule
à un policier
oui j'ai pris exactement mais ce qu'ils
aient passé ce que me brand
je perdais pas mal et puis un soir bon
j'étais seul à la table où je jouais là
à la roulette léger insulté le croupier
lorsqu'il avait fait ou pas une connerie
je ne me souviens pas clairement de la
soirée mes souvenirs ne correspond pas
aux films qu'ils ont tourné des
téléfilms et quand ils ont montré encore
quotidien qui n'est pas toujours
finalement vous traitez j'ai raconté
quand on quand on m'a mis en garde à vue
a raconté à la police qui s'était passé
mais après ils ont vu que ce n'était pas
comme ça du tout alors je qui s'est
passé en réalité ce qui est filmé sais
que je vais insulté très gravement
enfin avec des mots très violents et que
donc ils ont appelé le commissaire de la
police des jeux qui est venu pour
m'éjecter alors pour me dire monsieur
quitté le casino nom et le il est venu
avec les deux ou trois mineurs avec lui
du casino qui étaient des malabars lui
aussi d'ailleurs cela malabat et ému m
entouré pour me faire sortir
et moi j'ai une agoraphobie j'ai peur
des foules
enfin je ne fis j'aime pas me sentir
contraints par une foule alors et le
film montre ça je dis ne me touchez pas
ne me touchez pas et personne ne me
touchez - mais il était tout autour de
moi et alors en me retournant comme ça
j'étais une espèce le genre je me
débattais coin dans ma tête et je me
retourne comme ça et je vois c'était
malheureusement c'était pas un des
videurs c'était la commissaire de police
lui même qui est aveugle à lui donner un
petit coup de boule et bill
ga enfin bon on en est là et il n'a pas
eu et je crois qu'il a eu un jour
d'arrêt de travail parce que il est venu
témoigner parce qu'il est venue le
lendemain on a passé la journée à
témoigner elle a souvent quand on a les
jetons mets un coup de boule sans
réflexe du casino
voir
à demain
alors ma vous avez eue dans votre vie
des hauts et des bas comme tout le monde
et on va faire une interview à peine
d'armes
[Musique]
omar sharif ce que vous préférez en vous
ma ma chance la chance que j'ai ouais
c'est pas en moi c'est fini sur une
bonne chose une bonne étoile mais une
chance folle toute ma vie vous voyez pas
été plus heureux si vous aviez vécu au
caire finalement avec faten hamama en
étant une star cairote en étant une star
égyptienne -l'un c'est possible je ne le
saurai jamais je ne saurai jamais si ce
qui serait arrivé si on m'avait pas pris
pour laurent sahabi il est fort possible
que j'aurais été plus heureux dans ma
vie oui parce que vous soyez aussi
peut-être pas comme ça dans une chambre
docteur igor l'uréthane par un
patriarche amis patriotes corses à ce
que vous haïssez en vous je n'ai rien en
moi parce que quand je fais quelque
chose je l'aï c'est quelque chose en
moins je ferai de tous pour corriger
cette chose que je vais d'ailleurs un
peu plus beaucoup de fric
c'était en 66 fric
j'ai gagné un million $ au casino parce
que j'étais avec une jeune j'étais dans
le nord de l'italie
il y avait une starlette qui était
assise à côté de moi qui étais très très
bien et on est allé à la discothèque on
a flirté tout pigé dit de monter avec
moi chez elle voulait bien prendre un
verre dans ma chambre m'a dit non
j'étais fou de rage et j'avais bu pas
mal et je suis allé au casino et jeux
joué le numéro que je ne joue jamais
c'est à dire le 29 à la roulette et ses
sorties 4 x 2 from exclusion tu réalises
élabore coup et alors le lendemain j'ai
acheté toutes les fleurs d'interflora 1
et j'ai envoyé un camion parce que tu es
aller à rome j'ai envoyé un camion de
fleurs à cette jeune dame 1 qui était
dans le nord tout à fait 2,5 tonnes 5
tonnes de fleurs vient quelle est son
nom elle est devenue floride surdose de
l'umih président et inélégamment une
carte qui disait vous auriez été le coup
le plus cher de ma vie le plus grosses
pertes c'est quand vous êtes obligés de
vendre ou de votre appartement
oui j'ai oui j'ai aussi c'était dans ses
ordres à cet homme là et c'était tout
l'argent que possédait au monde à ce
moment là en banque en banque
le plus grand moment de votre vie
difficile le plus grand moment j'ai
peut-être fait pas la naissance de mon
fils juin probablement j'adore mon fils
je suis vraiment aux fanatiques de mon
fils est la mienne aussi
le pire moment le jeu ne s'est pas assez
là c'est tous les moments de déchéance
physique quand quand on est malade et
que les nerfs doivent s'occuper de vous
et vous accompagne et à la salle de bain
c'est tellement atroce
j'étais malade vous chez j'ai eu et j'ai
fait un pontage et eut annoncé changer
une hanche
c'est une prothèse j'ai une prothèse
vous suivez plus là non je fais même pas
à manger à rester aux tests et fo n'ont
eu un miracle pour arrêter de fumer
1 parce que je fumais 100 cigarettes par
jour et un jour j'ai eu mal à la
poitrine et j'ai compris que cette
écriture de cardiaque
alors comme je ne savais pas qu'il
parlait j'ai regardé le plafond et je
lui ai parlé
j'ai des doutes je n'ai jamais parlé
avant je te dire maintenant si tu me
fais vivre jusqu'à demain matin j'arrête
de fumer
bon et puis j'ai arrêté puis j'aime pris
une cigarette pour allumer j'ai eu un
choc électrique est contré mise dans ma
bouche
j'ai été très malade j'ai vomi g
no est terrible et depuis je n'ai plus
pu toucher une cigarette
vous arrivez alors karim et je lui ai
plus jamais parler j'attends vos vidéos
déplacez l'émission on applaudit dieu
peut plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
faten hamama j'imagine oui sûrement
insurgées massées massage et puis tous
les autres qui font remarquer sophie
davant evelyne dhéliat marie ange nardi
oui la plus minable
marie-ange nardi vous savez quelle
mesure elle même mais non
j'attends
et
un jour quand elle était à la pyramide
qu'elle faisait la meilleure amie la
sueur des pyramides
il ya eu une question sur moi 1 donc on
a dix qui est à jouer docteur lui avoir
un truc comme ça
elle a pas su répondre quelque et après
on l'a dit mais c'est omar sharif bien
sûr elle a dit mais j'ai jamais entendu
parler ou alors tu vois je ris marion
j'ai eu une aventure avec elle 82 marché
c'est pas comme sophie davant bien alors
votre vote vous êtes plus minables
histoire d'amour
tiens on vient me faisait me lave
l'histoire d'un monde ça a été avec rita
hayworth non oui c'était j'ai eu une
aventure pigments stupéfiante avec un
peu je l'admirais beaucoup depuis que
j'étais très jeune et asseoir l était l
avais assez bu et je les raccompagner
chez elle elle habitait sur les eaux de
cannes ont fait tourner un film ensemble
et moi j'habitais à nice et quand on est
arrivé il m'a dit ce que vous voulez
prendre un verre je descends un avait
une voiture de la production avec un
chauffeur je vais avec elle elle avait
un bar qui était en berne m'a dit vous
aimez le vin blanc
j'ai compris que c'est ce qu'elle
voulait que je boive j'ai pris un verre
de vin blanc de verre et puis on a
flirté en la flore tu es très bientôt
et puis au moment où on était au point
de haut point culminant de notre
relation
elle me dit mais vous croyez que vous
allez me sauter vous je tiens n'ont
jamais parce qu'il aurait un jour hamas
mais abou diaby qui était partout jours
qu'ils ont créé un jeté mes copains elle
me dit allez sortez vous êtes vous
croyez que vous êtes arrivé vous avez
tourné un film à wingles hollande
d'arabie je vous avais laissé jusqu'à
oui mais elle était sous la peau
informatique
bref elle me dit sortez alain je sors et
a pas la voiture
alors je dis mais où est la voiture et
le mini leur envoyer marché et jeu et
j'ai fait de l'auto-stop à 5 heures du
matin j'ai dit à sa maman
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que on va garder la cuve est
aussi un bruit mais elle était adorable
ans y était même vraiment mais vraiment
ma copine si vous préférez dans le sexe
les préliminaires et bada c'était le cas
je serais content que mes virées avant
mon pour traiter ce qui vous dégoûte le
plus dans le sexe de l'après sexe quand
ça se passe mal
quand quand on se retourne chacun de son
côté contre 1 017 afin qu'on doive se
rhabiller partir desquels pas de bagnole
chacal michaël youn elsa pataky calais
au magot
[Applaudissements]
michael lui même là-bas tactique à des
oliviers
tout le monde connaît michael tien bo
magloire train peut présenter notre ami
elsa pataky qui est vraiment
extraordinaire je me demande si je vais
arriver à faire l'émission s'est tu
crois mais je te regarde et toi tu est
un testeur de pas dérapé voilà c'est
peut-être la bonne idée oui je pense à
la cour saïda que si tu dérapes avec
magloire c'est plus dangereux car dans
le dans le film alors vous avez été élue
elle a la fille la plus désirée
d'espagne dire que vous avez été élu par
des hommes et par des femmes ce qui est
très bien parce qu'en général vous
plaisez plutôt aux hommes c'est vrai que
je préfère quelques unes des femmes
disent à quel les hommes le sont c'est
plus facile moins cher j'aime pas trop
facile ouais en france ça serait pareil
ah oui oui je suis sûr je suis le
français le plus chanceux alors si vous
étiez à madrid en 1976 paire espagnole
mère roumaine alors votre grand-père
était comédien et il vous montrer
toujours des albums avec des photos de
tournage et quand vous étiez petit vous
voyez ces photos et vous avez dit c'est
ça que je veux faire quoi c'est vraiment
voilà un oui c'est comme ça c'est hélas
fait beaucoup de théâtre en roumanie
et oui des consuls à petit la jouer avec
moi et fait des personnages de rôle moi
toujours la princesse ouais
elle est très heureux de faire ça et
comment juger a vaincu avec lui que je
dis je perds je dirais que je comprends
pas tout ce qu'elle dit mais j'adore son
accent ce tabouret moi non plus on te
comprends très bien
c'est arrivé déjà et des femelles par le
français des gens bien célébrer les
traditions et j'assure la traduction du
manque c'est pas du nietzsche ça va tu
es gustaf et la fiom ces faits la jeune
fille vous connaissez pas fils et lui
m'a pris deux mots mais samedi c'est la
fondation s'est dit c'est là la payanne
en est donnée salah mamah de pedro
l'autre chose qui est bien c'est fini
as tu peux aller en vacances à ibiza
mossad à playa voilà voilà
il ya des rendez vous des tomates comme
les seins coniques la dynastie des tang
jitian dominique hummel
mais tout le monde en parle et regarder
en espagne sur la rue on va l'arrêter
le monde doit black et bien je continue
la vie de sa place est acquis que nos
amis ne connaissent pas encore très bien
mais ça ne va pas tarder donc d'abord de
la télévision ensuite du cinéma un pas
mal de films et la première rencontre
avec michael c'était la première
rencontre
non moi je l' ai vu en photo la première
fois dans le bureau de patrick braoudé
ouais et je dirais est bonne
[Musique]
et le pire c'est que je suis pas les
seuls à avoir dit ça boudreau moi je
suis reparti avec tout le monde
tout le monde de savoir quelles
techniques de drague tu as choisi
michael je me suis fait passer pour
vincent cassel a encore maintenant elle
pense que je m'appelle vincent cassel et
quand je suis là l'incarnation du mal le
mal avec un accent circonflexe 1
elle s'est blessée pas que j'ai fait
morning live et c'est pas je m'en prends
toile tout ça ne comprend pas d'accord
qu'un mot série michael youn la comédie
française lorsqu'il faut dire quand même
elsa c'est que avant michael youn vous
saviez déjà eu à faire un
exhibitionniste donc à l'âge de 13 ans
vous avez été attaqué par un petit peu
rencontrer des collègues à moi ouais le
type qui vous a poursuivi jusque dans
l'ascenseur à celle qu à l ascenseur est
ce qu'il ya un monsieur qui est venu
tout nu dans un ascenseur oui oui c'est
l'école j'ai deux petits mois on peut t
il j'avais a du sens et pour moi c'est
le touchpad jarretelles c'est pour ça
c'est sûr que là bas mais oui c'est un
ascenseur que c'est la première fois que
je veux un homme un homme alors ouais
non ça va marcher
c'est vrai alors tiens une question
intime là est ce que c'est vrai que dans
l'intimité contrairement à la télévision
il montre jamais ses fesses jamais
[Applaudissements]
comment ça se fait que j'ai choisi
michaël youn parler tous les acteurs du
film paca des opa magloire regarde
sergine quand même tu es au courant
c'est le mec qui est devenu star le plus
vite
ever c'est à dire qu'en trois ans il
avait déjà fait de la télé du cinéma de
la radio est d'ailleurs ce que dit assez
souvent car il me dit ben maintenant il
faudrait peut-être qu'il t'arrive
quelque chose pour que ça s'arrête là
que ce soit bien non si c'est ce que tu
m'as dit l'autre jour battu pour que tu
reste une légende il faudrait que tu
disparaisses il pourrait mourir
ces gros matches oui oui oui
bon là je fais une parenthèse sur les
relations de travail que nous avons avec
ce jeune femme
d'abord c'est une grande professionnelle
très sympathique et voilà mais j'ai
progressé emprunt c'est parce que c'est
vrai elle prend à regretter le premier
jour lorsqu'elle est arrivée qu'il était
évident qu'il allait [ __ ] la merde
parce qu'un film de mecs avec que des
hommes
et quand elle est arrivée la première
fois que je les ai vu une quinzaine oui
parce que justement je resterai
merci facile kg arrivé à mu pataky je me
suis dit oh là là ça va être le merdier
maintenant ils vont tous se taper c'est
vrai c'est un petit peu le nôtre a
ajouté qu on nomme des gens des adultes
des gens responsables
en tout cas même qui est tous les deux
ans par son nom était uniquement dubosc
mais bon quand elsa a vu le papier
d'identité de francs qu'elle a vu qu'il
avait 65 ans du bon comme du boss s'est
rattrapé sur les masseuses sur les
masseuses la balle voilà à marrakech on
appelle ça plutôt d'aider puta
professionnels des professeurs aux faits
mais qui ne passe pas comme ça parfois
le mas aussi
10 30 il en a marre l'ani arrête de dire
à la télé que je ne sais pas de toi
d'arrêter ce sens de l'ena ce sujet
moyen d'un téléphone qui sonne pendant
l'émission c'est pour sam karmann c'est
pourquoi y attendait oui c'est pas luis
figo tiens c'est pourquoi
kad merad c'est pour nelson mandela
gloria gaynor eavis carmouze parce qu'il
ya dix ans alors arrivé très bien madame
mais je peux passer des coûts série
ardisson il est très bien madame il à
moi aussi j'aime beaucoup s'en vont
connaître parce que vous m'aimez en
connaissant mes jeux wii vont connaître
et alors il a le thème c'est qu'il est
un peu les yeux cernés en ce moment mais
ce qu est ce qu ils se masturbent ou
deux rappels
mais on ne sait même pas qui fait de la
télévision pense-t-il à l'eau sèche et
la purée mr ben ouais je travaille la
préfecture de calais concours se
masturbe beaucoup la préfecture de
maladie à ses repas les derniers dans la
poste j'ai envie de faire une pause
bizet ou mad et l'émission a pas
commencé qu un quart d'heure écoute
vas-y mais tu sais pas ce qui va
t'arriver non mais sur la joue
fais gaffe tu sais je suis ta vu
maintenant je me fais beau gosse et
touche devient violent ouais bon enfant
ouais non pas traquer notamment trek
comme ça toute la journée c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on lui tire les cheveux
aussi clémentine célarié and so avec
clémentine célarié à l'as d'or qu'on lui
tirait aussi clémentine j'en sais rien
mais je suppose
moi j'aime bien aussi comme tu as par
les cheveux
nous
cadets on dirait les deux vieux du
muppet show me dis qu'on est des dieux
ils disent ah oui je sais pas mais la
route sérieux mon tuteur nissim sa a
énormément
[Applaudissements]
il
et puis
belle pour cet homme le prix d'un bel de
l'humour
songeur
[Applaudissements]
je réponds un bar un peu oui allô maman
savais pas ça va je suis en train de
faire tirer ardisson ça t'embête si on
se rappelle et pourquoi ne s'appelle pas
nous on n'a pas d'amis zou on va couper
au portable si ces écoutes le mieux
c'est que je te le pass maman je te le
passé ils me semblaient jetés à l'eau ça
va étude est pas étonnant avec comme
vous l'avez fait celui-là avec comment
vous l'avez fait celui-là mais il est
extraordinaire tout ce qui fait ici
votre fils d'écouter les gens écouter
les gens
[Applaudissements]
oui madame il a les yeux un peu cernés
en ce moment dans
si vous pensez qu'ils se masturbe
beaucoup lui dis pas pour la soirée dans
la boîte
non elle n'est pas là ce soir non on
peut dire on peut dire ce cas oui à
voile à terme explique que comme elsa
est en espagne c'est un petit peu obligé
voilà elle te elle te connais bien
quand même merci madame joue sous leurs
pas il a les yeux un peu cernés bonne
maman je te ra oui oui d'accord tout le
monde tu embrasses sauf ma gloire
lorsqu'elle s'est pas ma mère c'est que
je ne sais pas parce que de ça et là que
je me masturbe le mans ah oui d'accord
parlez nous de votre personnage on ne
fait le rôle de l'onudc donc je compose
ici un rôle de composition absolument je
peux vous prouvez immédiatement
évidemment que c'est un rôle de
composition
[Musique]
m
ah bon
monique la demie baguette de bonnes
segway troisième guiboles je vois que
c'est la première fois à la télévision
que l'animateur toucherait que donne
indiqué je pense que c'est bien avec les
démissions thierry ardisson la quête
d'eux mêmes
en quoi un prix là - était rct dope
je vends ce retour qui les vendent les
vents
[Rires]
michael c'est parti pour être un carton
encore cette histoire non je ne sais pas
mais si non je ne sais pas dépendants il
ne faut pas jurer que par le succès
d'hier il le succès est une drogue
absolument terrible j'essaye d'en sortir
en ce moment le problème c'est que ça va
encore faire monter votre votre cote au
box-office on va dire que vous irez et
mieux vaut à faire que les autres on va
rappeler que vous avez fait des études
marketing moi j'ai jamais forcé j'ai
jamais mis un couteau sous la gorge des
gens pour aller voir un film ou pour
acheter un disque en boîte je leur fais
pas prendre d ecstasy pour qui dansent
sur ma musique en spectacle je les force
pas je les force pas à rire donc on peut
bien sûr tout expliquer par le marketing
mais il ya un moment si les choses si
les gens rigolent c'est peut-être aussi
parfois parce que les choses sont drôles
oui dit michael ont fait pas ça jean
reno par exemple non c'est vrai c'est
vrai que jean reno on lui reproche
on lui reproche pas de gagner beaucoup
d'argent par fini on lui reproche pas de
bien gérer sa carrière lors qu'ils
gèrent très très bien sa carrière mais
peut-être parce que jean reno il n'a pas
fait d'études marketing
moi j'en ai fait rien luchini on lui dit
padt était super bien coiffé on le film
bat c'est normal il était coiffeur est
ce que vous savez combien il gagne
non j'avais vu le jour même capital non
non non les chiffres de capital sont
mangés je pense que c'est mieux si on
n'en parle pas parce que je suis un
petit peu en litige avec eux parce
qu'ils ont communiqué des chiffres qui
sont absolument pas qui sont absolument
pas vrai quoi un nom en particulier sur
le one man show aux cds même sur tous
les artistes qui sont concernés c'est
des chiffres qui sont très très loin de
la réalité
si on pouvait gagner 5 millions d'euros
avec un one man show tout le monde en
frais ouais j'ai commencé à prendre des
cours
c'est vrai vraiment béjaïa cette dame
est pas très très bien renseignés elle
va avoir des problèmes pas qu'avec moi
d'ailleurs il ya la grande confrérie des
comités centraux les vendredis soirs
vous dites j'ai tellement de succès
qu'on finit par plus me considérait
comme un artiste bombe se faire qu'en ce
moment c'est vrai qu'il ya une petite
période là depuis 2 puis 6 suis moi on
me parle surtout de alors pourquoi ça a
marché
est ce que les autres vont marcher
combien ce que vous aviez vous avez
gagné on ne parle pas de ce que je fais
concrètement même si pour certains c'est
pas assez sur 1,7 c'est peut-être pas du
beckett ce que je fais vous voyez pas
que les gens attendent maintenant autre
chose de vous après tous ces films et
attendent un truc un peu comme tchao
pantin pour coluche je dirige est tourné
trois films
ouais c'est iznogoud c'est le troisième
ouais je sais pas si des gens dont on
attend beaucoup ben dis donc c'est très
flatteur ça me fait plaisir en même
temps mais laissez moi un petit peu de
temps j'ai tourné que tant singh avait
déclaré au départ je voulais jouer
molière shakespeare tchekhov
oui mais j'en avais marre de bouffer du
riz tous les jours donc voilà c'est
peut-être ça qui amène sa non mais moi
j'ai presque fait de l'humour par hasard
ouais j'étais j'ai fait de la radio et
de la radio je suis venu à la télévision
et à la télévision je savais pas quoi il
sert à ce morning live donc j'ai dit je
vais faire ce que je fais depuis 30 ans
puisque je m'entraîne le plus patent je
vais faire le con hein
c'est ce que je fais le mieux
apparemment et et puis s'est trouvé que
ça plus marcher dans cette voie lac
quand je que quand je je je je faisais
le misanthrope boutons et des pères je
voulais un jour j'aimerais m'imposer
dans un truc sérieux j'aimerais
travailler que chéreau un jour oui voilà
donc
ces vies qui tendait un peu la perche
aussi c'est que 53 ans j'ai encore
quelques années c'est vrai donc borden
non mais si j'ai envie de durer dans ce
métier il faut que je me laisse le temps
aussi de faire les choses si je veux
déjà faire des rôles dramatiques au bout
de quatre ans qu'est ce qu'il va me
rester après une légion d'honneur
peut-être un prix nobel de la paix je
voudrais être pape mais bon je suis même
pas catholique sara est chiant jésus
était juif
oui c'est vrai que ça a bien marché sa
petite affaire ça a bien marché avec
elsa intéressement bien non mais tu m'as
dit elle me fait là à la maison fendi
d'un pas très drôle les blagues sur
annuler tout ça alors michael après
votre passage chez marc-olivier fogiel
on m'avait dit bon à ce moment là le
masque est tombé
et finalement j'étais plus michaël youn
j'étais redevenu ce que je suis au fond
c'est à dire michael benayoun et
finalement les gens dans le dans le
public sur le plateau ont trouvé ça pas
terrible mais dans la rue les gens vont
c'était ma meilleure amie un projet
jamais un tue jamais vendu autant de
tickets pour le spectacle que qu'après
cette émission et tous les gens depuis
que je rencontre dans la rue tu as bien
fait tout le monde devrait faire comme
toi être sincère à la fin mai mais c'est
vrai que voilà ce soir là j'avais pas je
n'avais pas forcément envie de combinés
il faut quand même prévenir un petit peu
les téléspectateurs dans la vie de tous
les jours on est on est pas toujours
comme ça parler de cette façon s'est
exprimé sur tel ou tel sujet là l'espace
d'un instant j'ai pu voulu être michael
youn j'ai voulu être juste moi même m'a
demandé d'être sincère je dis bah tu me
saoules ton émission de soul et je me
casse voilà et alors et l'erreur c'était
que j'aurais pas dû aller dans cette
émission quand on n'a pas envie de se
faire pisser dessus on va pas dans les
urinoirs sait tous où là
donc les masques vont à nouveau tombé ce
soir on va faire une interview michael
benayoun
[Musique]
marco enough d'une blague sur les
urinoirs mais lors je déconne à les
embrasse guy alors mickael benhaim ouais
on va parler michaël youn eux
est ce que tu trouves qu'il a la grosse
tête non mais il a bien bien pété les
plombs
mais il a tellement pété les plombs
qu'il a fait péter les plombs à tout son
entourage
il a fait péter les plombs à ses parents
ma mère maintenant elle avait en
permanence en contact avec mon avocat
mon agent elle fait ses courses en
string avec un mégaphone
mon père c'est pareil il répond aux
interviews des journalistes avec les
bras comme ça sur la tête
mes potes c'est pareil ils ont pété les
plombs se contourner en les 11
commandements maintenant quand ils font
des émissions de télé ils veulent qu'on
vienne les chercher en bagnole donc
voilà je vois plutôt que de dire que
c'est mon entourage qui me permet de
garder les pieds sur terre moi je perds
mais mon entourage de garder un petit
peu les pieds sur terre celle inverse
c'est le même mec dans l'intimité à la
télé où il joue un jeu quand il était là
télé danser comme tous les toutes les
personnes médiatique toutes les
personnes publiques
on n'est pas on n'est pas monolithique
qu'on a on a si je te fais chier tu vas
suspect siégeant cmc qui fait l'info
fait la promo du spectacle and so so
l'est où 5 minutes de muscat plus qu'un
poil de hamcho ils sont insensées d
apple n'est pas des personnalités
monolithique moi je suis pas qu'une
paire de fesses qui gueule je suis autre
chose mais quand même monde de même que
vous tirez quand on vous rend compte
dans la vie de tous les jours vous
n'êtes pas tout le temps avec vos fiches
non bien sûr d'ailleurs tu remarqueras
c'est pour ça que j'ai rien à dire
les gens disaient qu'il y ait comme ça
ils cherchent
dans ses poches jallet 6 mois dans la
vie michael youn c'est quelqu'un de sûr
de lui michaël youn oui oui quel
benayoun non non mais michaël youn et
dix mille fois plus intéressante michael
benayoun et c'est ce qui c'est michaël
youn qui donne de l'intérêt à la vie de
michael bay il a un beau cul ballard
différence mickael benhaim d'incubation
poilus alors que michaël youn a tendance
à le tondre parfois quand il ya un petit
peu trop de poils à michaël youn est
beaucoup plus cocaïne et des cravates
tôt michaël benayoun a fait un coup ça
tu penses que son succès dû à quoi
je sais pas il va y avoir une partie de
2,2 des gens de ma génération qui se
reconnaissent dans la même chose que moi
c'est à dire ceux qui sont ni très
pauvre ni très riches ceux qui viennent
vraiment du milieu les qui sont un petit
peu apolitique non pas de conviction
religieuse pas syndiqués qui sont un
petit peu désenchanté comme disait
mylène farmer
je pense qu'ils doivent se reconnaître
un petit peu dans la gamme donc dans la
violence de ce que je fais je crois
qu'il va durer j'espère que non parce
que je suis crevée crever c'est quand la
dernière fois que tu l'as vu pleurer
c'est à cause de toi des mois ouais si
si si
oh
le spectacle que michael youn plus qu'un
poil de l'eau autour tu me conseille
d'aller le voir
we saw je te conseille d'aller le voir à
partir du du 15 février au bataclan
jusqu'au 15 mai à mende accord alors et
c'est c'est celle tout ce qui avait de
bien dans plus qu'un poil saison un plus
tout ce qu'il ya de mieux dans plus
qu'un poil saison 2 c'est c'est plus
qu'un one man show c'est vraiment un
spectacle puisqu'il ya évidemment il ya
des sketches des perceuses mais il ya
des danseuses il ya barbara il y as tu
l'as d'or d'ailleurs barbara toi tu as
raison il ya des années il ya des
chansons il ya des happenings avec le
public c'est un peu un spectacle à à
l'armoricaine ouais c'est comme un
spectacle à l'américaine mais que les
moyens de l'en-avant guingamp quoi elsa
c'est la meilleure neuf qu'il ait jamais
n'ont ni kg gratuite oui
[Applaudissements]
mais si je réponds oui ça fait tu vois
après cela et c'est là au moins je reste
un peu moins marquée tu penses qu'il est
heureux michael malgré son succès
michaël youn je pense que michael youn
il il est plus heureux que michael
benayoun c'est plus simple pour lui
ouais voilà si tu pouvais lui donner un
conseil à michaël youn je dirais quoi
prends ton temps ouais 30 ans tu en
voilà tranquille parce que j'ai toujours
peur que le monsieur vient taper à la
pâte et viennent me dire s était
maintenant c'est pas l'argent il faut
tout rendre mais la fille aussi tard oui
la fille aussi qu'elle elle rigole en
plus
kaunas
m
et tu devrais ce rôle tu es parti pour
les césar au nom de son unité rue césar
alors tu la vis dans les fringues c'est
pas compliqué oui je voudrais remercier
michael youn pour parce qu'il était là
parce qu'il est là y parce qu'il sera là
oh
[Musique]
je me suis dit pendant le temps bracemac
rares comme la salle on y arriver
d'accord d'accord taille est vieille âme
support est à
le ménage est tout noir sur tontine et
jérôme et orgue
c'est de la peinture je voudrais
remercier mon dealer pour de ne plus
m'appeler
ça c'est un idéal
ça c'est vrai c'est traiter les
céphalées définit alors tu fous là tu
l'a vexé il va vraiment pu taper je
voudrais remercier dieu donné pour les
autres je voudrais remercier dieu pour
c'est peut-être la meilleure partie de
moi même donc merci dieu mais j'ai
touché c'est vrai que je voudrais
remercier thierry ardisson pour avoir
pensé à moi de temps en temps il croit
avoir cru en moi avant les autres
oui
et maintenant
voici bruce willis
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
d'avoir choisi le mandant pas
nous sommes très heureux que vous soyez
là ce soir
heureusement qu est ce que vous vous
êtes heureux à paris
dies 20 super super heureux j'adore
paris j'aime toujours venir ici les gens
sont toujours très sympa avec moi glisse
non habité ici je connais l'hôtel
l'hôtel vous êtes installé brouille
c'est un très bon hôtel vous connaissiez
d'hôtel à saint antoine
c'est un très bon hôtel très bien situé
bonne cuisine
voilà alors comment ça va avec les
parisiennes tout tout tout vraiment tout
malheureusement oui qu'est ce que vous
faites après l'émission mais je connais
des endroits si mal et je peut vous
amener après l'émission
ok est ce que vous pourriez vivre en
france bruce oui sans aucun doute jeu
pour éviter à paris sans aucun doute à
limoges
you know limoges away note limoges
spèce vous apprendriez le français si
vous habitiez en france via sa wii
japonaises ont porté au bar le sien à
dand est à la tour eiffel
alors si c'est bruce willis habiter en
france il pourrait faire des films avec
laurent baffie ce directeur à give you
mind over eigen vous avez une carte non
à l'avenant my movies assistant mon film
est chaud c'est vrai bien alors de toute
façon bruce willis n'a rien contre les
réalisateurs français puisque vous avez
fait le cinquième élément
avec luc besson et que votre nouveau
film otages et réalisé par florent syrie
alors quand on sait vous êtes l'auteur
denis dgs est sorti en 2002 avec benoît
magimel samy naceri nadia farès qui est
venu d'ailleurs ici pour ans pour en
parler et ce film nid de guêpes bruce
willis l'a vu à l'american film market
et il a été intéressé par votre travail
comment s'est passée votre première
rencontre à revoir ça s'est très bien
passé vraiment bien passé il m'a appelé
tout simplement il m'a laissé un message
sur mon répondeur je les ai rappelés on
s'est vus à los angeles
et puis voilà ça s'est bien passé avec
bruce il a été docile super vraiment
j'ai rien à dire ça a été d'abord une
super comment dirais-je rencontre plus
qu'une rencontre c'est devenu un ami
c'est quelqu'un de très ouvert très
simple il m'avait vraiment laissé faire
le film que je voulais faire c'était
important c'est vrai qu'un jour leur un
peu poussé dans ses retranchements et
vous a dit hu c'est florent j'ai fait
cinquante films et vous lui aurait
répondu moi j'en retiens que quatre
c'est pas tout à fait non c'est pas la
vérité en fait c'est vraiment très bien
entendu alors la fille de bruce willis
rumer willis joue dans le film est ce
que vous pensez qu'elle va faire une
carrière
ouais moi je suis sûr qu'elle va faire
une carrière mais qu'est ce qu'on te
rendre votre fille j'en suis oui elle
veut en tout cas ferrer vraiment été
super dans le film comme j'étais
producteur du film lui fait faire une
audition et donc elle est venue elle a
rencontré florent et donc c'est elle qui
a remporté le rôle mais bon les toujours
c'est toujours une gamine et si elle
veut vraiment faire carrière devenir
actrice et bien je l'aiderai ouais alors
règle absolue vos enfants n'ont le droit
de faire du cinéma que si vous ou démis
moore jouer dans le film quand ils ont
pas droit de faire des films sans vous
effectivement ils peuvent travailler
avec leur père ou avec leur mère et pour
nous ça nous permet de de les maintenir
enfants mais bon ils se sont vraiment
éclaté faisant ça ils grandissent
beaucoup en faisant ça dans les
tournages que ce soit avec leur mère aux
rythmes d'ailleurs l'impression que vous
donnez en tous les cas avec demi moore
vous êtes séparé mais l'impression que
vous donnez c'est d'arriver à préserver
très bien vos enfants on n'a pas
l'impression qu'ils qui souffre de sa
merci mais effectivement on est toujours
amis avec des millions dans le très bon
ami et donc quand on sait par et on
s'est mis d'accord pour eux essayé de
faire preuve d'intelligence et de
protéger nos enfants avant tout et pour
l'instant je veux dire que ça va fort
bien marché on est restés amis c'est
vraiment une très belle chance pour les
enfants et donc ça marche bien c'est un
demi divorce en fait
[Applaudissements]
depuis que vous êtes séparés on vous
prête bruce willis c'est normal c'est
très beau on vous prête toutes sortes
d'aventurés récemment vous avez été
obligé de démentir une liaison avec une
starlette de 18 ans qui s'appelle
lindsay lohan
alors oui c'est vrai il ya très peu de
choses qu'on peut faire quand on est
quand on est aussi connu pour ce que les
gens font toujours partie un moment ou
un autre
donc là j'ai été un petit peu trop loin
peut-être et donc ils les ont poursuivis
en justice ils ont dû présenter leurs
excuses mais bon eu 18 ans et c'était un
peu trop je ne peux tu aimerais vous
dites toute façon je devenu tellement
difficile maintenant qu'il ya que 2 % de
la population féminine dans le monde qui
peut me correspond donc c'est très
difficile pour vous maintenant de
trouver chaussure à votre pied comme on
dit oui c'est très difficile
effectivement mais bon je cherche
d'accord bas les filles maintenant vous
le savez est-il look et voilà alors vous
dites c'est difficile de savoir en fait
quand on voit arriver une fille quand on
est bruce willis parce que il ya écrit
jackpot ici et c'est très compliqué de
savoir si la fille est honnête c'est ça
avance et un pseudo oui je suis de
jackpot incarner oui je sais pas en tout
cas
je pense que c'est une question de
confiance tu n'as pas envie d'avoir une
aventure avec une masse haye pour avoir
un peu un regard vierge quelqu'un qui ne
te connais pas ou une inuit
[Rires]
non non je ne veux pas il ya un truc
très très drôle bruce willis etc
récemment dans le show de david
letterman à new york
vous avez sorti un dvd aux 4,7 avec la
vie sexuelle la vie sexuelle auto rièzes
c'est quoi c'est à dire que les bandes
qui était sûr sur internet vous avez
décidé de sortir en dvd c'est sa vie
sexuelle de bruce willis
il faut 5 dvd
[Musique]
merci
la première miss
m
[Musique]
la commission c'est vraiment super yeux
c'était moi qui chante ça s'appelait la
ça s'appelait le retour de bruno de
l'été un bonhomme est bourru chanter
plus maintenant ici je joue toujours jeu
je me produis avec mon groupe 2003 on
est allé en irak pour amuser ses troupes
mais c'est un petit secret quelque chose
que je fais toujours je fait différent
je fais la musique tout à fait
différente maintenant là ce qu'on a
entendu ça remonte à 18 mois
alors avec otages bruce willis vous
redevenez un héros donc on va faire une
interview antihéros bruce willis est ce
que vous avez déjà fermer votre gueule
devant un flic qui vous coller un pv
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black
à ces limbes la capelle alors quand
excuse moi le chèque bruce willis hockey
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black nom est devant un blague qui
s'en prenait à un fléau
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait semblant
de ne pas entendre quelqu'un qui vous
avez insulté alors oui vous êtes déjà
évanoui
on va voir parce que nous ça nous
arrange lâchement que ce soit un anti
héros quand est-ce que vous avez déjà
porter des chaussettes trouées par
exemple louis philippe salle non est-ce
que vous avez déjà exigé un cascadeur
pour une scène pourtant sans danger
ah non vous avez déjà demandé à des
techniciens de sortir du plateau au
moment où vous alliez vous mettre tout
nu vous ai déjà eu une panne sexuelle
avec une femme très entreprenante
c'est un héros
est-ce que vous avez déjà serré la main
de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez à et qui sortait des toilettes
sans se laver les mains est ce que vous
êtes déjà barré avant qu'une de vos
conquêtes ne se réveille
[Applaudissements]
j'écris mais non seulement du doigt le
matin est ce que vous êtes
oh
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille que c'était la femme de votre vie
pour coucher plus vite avec elle j'y
reste
le déjà profité qu'une fille soit bourré
pour coucher avec elle
oui voilà
non
des cadres van gogh grosse crise florent
vous devez vous laisser embrasser sur la
bouche par thierry ardisson et les turcs
et c'est moi ça me plaît
ces deux joueurs
[Applaudissements]
hi décédée il ya des millions et des
millions de filles qui m'envient ce soir
à rio de janeiro s'arrête sur les vidéos
classées x ça tu avais je sais pas si je
passe mon tour j'attends julia roberts
hockey
merci
[Applaudissements]
voici la linotte shield
animaux utiles bonsoir ça va l'adil
depuis la disparition du baron edmond
votre époux bas vous avez beaucoup de
temps libre
et comme vous avez beaucoup d'argent bah
vous visiter les endroits en europe ou
aux lieux les plus belles histoires
d'amour voilà c'est pas compliqué et
vous en rapporter un livre qui s'appelle
sur les chemins de l'amour et c'est
édité chez robert laffont
donc on commence avec 6,6 donc elle
faisait chambre commune avec françois
josef et à l'époque c'était une
révolution ça absolument et après non
après non parce que après il s'est passé
tellement de choses où elle est devenue
complètement une femme mystérieuse une
femme anorexique car elle a eu de tels
drames dans sa vie qu' effectivement
elle n'était pas mais j'ai très bien
connu
cet impératif à cause de ma belle mère
qui habitait le château de prony et sari
venait régulièrement au chanteur ronnie
donc elle était une grotte habitué je
dormais dans la chambre de 6,6 quand je
me suis marié à we met donc à l'époque
faire chambre commune c'était mal vu
je le suppose à fâches était pas là
cette époque un bon eh bien alors aussi
si si c'est elle qui choisissait la
maîtresse de son mari et c'est super
sympa à écouter et vous croyez que ça
lui dit simplement écouter les clubs de
rencontre qu'est ce que c'est c'est ça
hein ben c'est pas les femmes qui
choisissent les maîtresses et leurs
bungalows
non mais en grande partie si les femmes
laissent faire aujourd'hui c'est ça le
drame c'est que malheureusement elle non
plus si vous voulez 7
cette légèreté pour pouvoir dire cette
femme est charmante
aujourd'hui on divorce on balance et
puis c'est terminé
tu ferais ça toi jamais on dit que les
hommes aux sons ou à mon mari qu'est ce
que vous êtes
marie vous êtes mari oui c'est donc
concluent donc donc
j'y vais ça de choisir les maîtresses de
votre mari elle sait pas l'idée c'est du
groupe
[Applaudissements]
vous avez posé une question une phase de
l'émission est dit vous rentrez chez
vous en soyez dutronc lit avec une fille
et vous m'avez répond je suis dit qu'est
ce que vous faites mais a répondu je me
joins à eux
oui ça met beaucoup choqué j'ai mis 6
mois mon mari d une chose je te verrai
au lit avec monsieur je dirais que c'est
pas toi
ah c'est ça c'est ça l'éducation ce que
l'on a envie de saveurs on n'a pas envie
de savoir est ce qu'on a envie de garder
on a envie de voir la personne
s'éloigner c'est même moi je ferais la
même chose je vous verrai au lit avec
votre femme tirée c'est pas lui dans le
bouquin il ya 6 6 à lola montès la
pompadour bavaroise donc été avec loïc
premier de bavière qui perdra sans trop
de mer alors vous dites qu'elle n'a pas
su tirer profit de ces rencontres c'est
pas comme vous attendez attendez
attendez moi j'ai eu très peu de
rencontres mais elles ont été très
productives et si la super les femmes se
galvaude elles ne savent pas choisir ce
mois là je donne tout de suite à tout le
monde n'y a pas beaucoup de recul non
plus c'est difficile on revient toujours
à cette phrase ya beaucoup de recul
vous avez c'est vrai dans la rue les
gens disent qu'on doit il ya 40 millions
d'hommes sur la place de paris en france
bon il n'y a pas non plus que des gens
qui peuvent pas faire votre bonheur les
hommes font votre bonheur faut pas être
rothschild pour ça vous parlez de george
sand aussi wii qui part donc ouais et
alors il faut un ménage à trois je
savais pas et que les docteurs avec
pagaie lola baï d'ingrid bergman aussi
hollande lieberman c'est terrible ce qui
lui est arrivé parce que rossellini
roberto rosselini devenu fou d'amour
pour elle il l'a épousée il lui a fait
un enfant le fameux robertino étaient
divorcés
oui il a fait du français et quand elle
a eu sept enfants après il l'aimait plus
parce que c'était la maman et mais c'est
normal c'est logique les femmes
s'imagine toujours quelles vont-être des
maîtresses toute la vie c'est pas vrai
on est maîtresse tant qu'il y as
séduction tant qu'il y a fantasme
après lorsqu'il y a un enfant la femme
en effet plus forte assise mais dont
science exacte bien sûr les wampas nos
clubs aux enfants quand le gosse était
dans la pièce à côté vous pouvez pas
faire des galipettes c'est normal c'est
vrai c'est vrai bon ben cheyrou l'enfant
à la pièce est de mettre assez loin
jetez un oeil à deux changements le
métro entre le seul dans la chambre puis
laissant à chaque les noms mais c'est
fini c'est selon mais c'est made in the
mad et c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu
quarante ans sinon j'arrête pas fait je
n'avais pas fait trois jeux ouais mais
vous savez que françoise hardy et
jacques dutronc ils font vous fait
toujours un appartement à part c'est
bien moi je fais ça aussi c'est ça et
alors nadine vous arriver finalement au
taj mahal et là vous achetez le kama
sutra lors s'agit comme je savais
exactement parler mais j'y crois pas je
vais pas me dire que vous avez attendu
tout ce temps pour acheter le kama sutra
made in je vous donne ma parole
et là j'ai réalisé que j'avais tout faux
ah bon mais tout en fait en fait avec
et qu'est ce que ça aurait été si vous
l'avez tenu quarante ans en kama sutra
imaginaire gérer toute la famille roach
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve les médias de toutes ces
histoires n'ont pas quand on connaît la
vôtre c'est cent fois mieux votre
histoire vous non c'est vrai que je suis
une des rares femmes d'abord je devrais
être dans dans le livre des records et
s'est marié 40 ans avec un homme comme
était mon mari c'était pas du site est
pas facile tous les jours vous savez la
10e la plage bien des photos d'animaux
sauna mais ce qui prouve qu'ils prouvent
leur ans et que j'ai fait le tour du
monde pour l'agresser libyens sur les
photos soir je me suis donné beaucoup de
mal pour arriver à pondre un livre qui
va faire rêver mes lectrices parce que
qu'est ce qu'elles ont envie d'entendre
c'est parler d'amour moi oui votre époux
et bien oui oui oui je pense pas qu'elle
va l'acheter tout de suite mais pourquoi
d'aller lui acheter
non je ne pense que si c'est toi aussi
tu devrais fermer dix ans est enceinte
c'est un très beau et j'ai plutôt me
donner ce qu'ils me anne il en est même
pas question c'est très triste la saison
ils ont fait partenaire en chine
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire de nadine non oui vous étiez
jeune comédienne nous avons rencontré
non mais ça commence avant cela dit nenê
en banlieue
1 donc c'est bien avant des jets
comedian l'ouvrière dans un deux pièces
et aller chercher l'eau dans la cour tu
as donc c'était quand même assez quand
même senti le premier amour de nadine
été chiffonniers ah oui il avait vous
cherchez des fleurs dans les poubelles
et vous les avez fait c'est une très
belle histoire à 14 ans vous vous
retrouvez en train de travailler dans
une usine de housses de voitures chennai
bailleurs et mêmes pour faire un peu
d'argent de poche le soir quand vous
rentrez vous l'avez le marbre de
l'escalier de l'immeuble c'est ça n'est
pas voilà non mais attends c'est une
montée de causette
attention cet hymne c'est pas les
misérables mais quand même il ya un côté
cause est très bien sorti et alors donc
vous commencé par rencontrer le peintre
jean gabriel domergue qui pour qu'ils
vous devenez modèle
ensuite vous êtes effectivement danseuse
meneuse de revue comédienne à l'âge de
17 ans il l'a hélas à partir de la jazz
ella ella nadine se dit j'ai pas le
physique de la star quoi je vois là
quand je vais pas y arriver comme ça et
elle se dit me reste une solution c'est
vrai cela dit il reste le mariage sauf
que le mail se sera retirée à dix ans de
traque
non non pas de trois pour dieu j'étais
charmante j'étais tout à fait tout à
fait agréable pour un homme pourquoi
est-ce que hier soir était la traque de
mon côté pas du tout parce que c'était
un animal rare dont vous fait les choses
il faut bien vous dire quand vous
rencontrez une femme c'est pas elle qui
vient vous chercher
c'est vous qui la découvrit ouais non
d'ailleurs la première fois c'est bien
la première fois qu'il vous a vu demande
rothschild il vous a dit vous êtes la
femme de ma vie
absolument voilà absolument je n'ai pas
cru d'ailleurs mais cela était vrai
puisque ça a duré 40
il venait de se marier en plus et non
mais t'as ton pennavienne un quart dans
ta trompé c'était dans des livres mes
enfants mes enfants je ne suis pas j'ai
toujours
vous savez connaissez les trois petits
singes ouais c'est vrai quand vous
appelez à la ruée vers l'or quand même à
l'époque oui on m'a toujours dit on m'a
toujours dit que j'étais fait pour avoir
beaucoup d'argent et vous auriez dû le
voir effectivement dans vos mains vous
voir vous allez me dire si vous passez
vous prédire le passé c'est bien je
crois que vous avez tessier sera mieux
pour enfin le fait bien donc je continue
à les jambes de nadine de rothschild
donc effectivement vous rencontrez
demande rothschild mais évidemment il ya
un handicap il vient de se marier avec
une fille sublime d'ailleurs il est
l'héritier d'une prestigieuse dynastie
financière il est juif pas vous ce qui
ne simplifie pas du tout les choses
après vous êtes converti mais mais ça je
pas trouvé qu'il y avait des problèmes
jésus était juif absolue absolument
joseph aussi alors je vais à l'amiable
et alors là pendant trois ans vous êtes
la femme de l'ombre
vous êtes dans un appartement à la
muette quoi la vue est d'où le nom à
l'époque
vous savez aujourd'hui toutes les femmes
sont plus ou moins plus ou moins comment
on appelle comment dit-on non mais je
savais pas voulu en venir dont
appréhender jamais été maîtresse non à
l'accord du conteur ou l'art dans une
autre vie
rahman le têt donc voilà un jour vous
êtes enceinte et le bar en vous épouser
voilà non il ne m'a pas non attention ça
mais c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas
comme ça il a décidé qu'un jour nous
allions faire un enfant
d'accord j'ai pris la décision en ce
sens mais comment lui pouvait faire un
enfant dans la clandestinité
je vous savez écouter aujourd'hui le 5 à
7 qu'est ce que vous faites l'après midi
entre 5 le buzz mais et la voilà donc
finalement vous rentrez dans la famille
rothschild vous vous convertissez tout
va bien et vous devenez la baronne de
rothschild voilà et alors vous mettez au
point mort fameuse théorie à ce moment
là sur l'homme roi 1 l'homme quand même
roy l'homme est naturellement un fidèle
c'est l'élite et âme au féminin ou
masculin dire à ma femme en regardant la
caméra là je vais lui dire en sortant
d'accord la grande théorie nadine c'est
que le vrai féminisme c'est de mener les
hommes par le bout du nez en fait c'est
ça le vrai bien entendu on a tous les
pouvoirs ici mais c'est un euphémisme
c'est pas honnête tu penses il change
pas après les excuses et le laisser
l'histoire elle tirait le diable par la
queue
pourquoi la queue
[Applaudissements]
g
ça recoupe des emails la dignité sur un
carré sans cesse pourquoi là que tu as
beau pays mais voilà que c'est ma
demande tout seul et à nadine panien
bruno non ça ne m'est adressée
personnellement à l'assemblée en réponse
la lune on est sans aucun doute mais
j'ai dû la trouvait d'ailleurs voilà
donc vous devenez une grande spécialiste
de la stratégie amoureuse à ce moment-là
nadine de rothschild les règles de
savoir vivre les bonnes manières en
facteur la table le plan de table
exactement l'étiquette absolument et on
va faire une interview dîner chez les
rothschild
[Applaudissements]
nadine est ce que le retard est
tolérable
je pars du principe que les gens qui
arrivent à l'heure ne doivent pas
attendre celui qui n'est pas à l'heure
alors je me mets à table avec mes
invités et les gens arrivent après et
croyez moi ils n'arrivent pas deux fois
en retard et vous fermait pas la porte
quand même vous les laisser arriver
jeunesse arrivent et gagneront la
vaisselle d'accord alors on doit
apporter quoi quand on va dîner chez les
gens en général on envoie des fleurs à
la recherche des décédés mais sinon
aujourd'hui à des mets
et quand on a mangé chez moi ça rit
souvent jamais seul quand c'est des amis
quand c'est des amis quand c'est des
amis on apporte quoi nadine si j'habite
monsieur a dit alors vivement la faille
ils m'envoient des fleurs la veille
c'était le lendemain ils font déjà
partie des aspects mais vous avez aussi
le lendemain effectivement le droit
d'envoyer alors faut-il manger de tout
ça on est obligées d'y habiter
bravo le nom si vous avez un ami
diabétiques la maîtresse de maison sa
forme avant pour on sait que nos belles
montagnes à payer le monde alors il y
avait forcément bien alors la question
très importante
est ce que la télé peut rester a dit qu
il encore dit c'est une émission comme
tout le monde en parle une spéciale qui
veut gagner des millions
question pour un champion je dînais avec
vous peut-être oui ah oui oui on est
happé en tête à tête on court avec ses
ateliers
non parce que je m'ennuierais peut-être
aujourd'hui
xxl bien est ce qu'on peut faire du pied
sous la table dit mais comment c'est
même recommandé au fumage aussi offert
aux passants des pièces est-ce que la
main baladeuse est autorisée ouais ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas comment dirais je
sais pas tout ce qui est un peu
hypocrite sous la table ce sont paul
faire un cd à 9,7 mm ça vous est déjà
arrivé de faire du plat une femme en lui
passant la main comme ce coup là bas lui
mais pas chez moi raconte n'importe quoi
dans la banque rothschild en compte mais
oui mais oui c'est pas idiot à un
découvert autorisé la voix si vous payez
en nature peut-être mais j'ai craqué
pas mal c'est pas tomber dans leurs
idées à leur faire ça non je cherche mon
sens pleure mais je ne trouve pas qu'il
l'oublié chez toi ensuite non mais je me
mets pas non c'est un peu too much
québécois bien non nadine c'était quoi
s'était passé dont je suis le fondateur
jean cauchy dominion
siro
tu parles en images les allemands ont eu
des cours non bien alors nadine est ce
qu'on peut se soucier que son pain
est-ce que fossé s'est trompé
oui bien parce qu'on peut dire tout le
temps n'avait par exemple pas société
mais je suis surprise aujourd'hui par la
génération des femmes qui vous disent
ouais ouais tu dire oui bon quand vous
dites à un homme qui se réalise
est-ce que tu même si on vous demandait
ce que tu m'aimes
elle répondrait je t'aime au lieu du ruy
je t'aime et toute la différence dont
elle s'ajuste
et quel est l'avenir c'est le bordel
c'est pour ça qu'il ya la guerre il
pensait jamais rien madame plus
sérieusement à des écoutes moi qu'elle
est là ne la manque
ça va partir mais quand elle est là la
plus grosse gaffe qu'on puisse faire un
dîner chez toi de ne pas venir
c'est une belle et jolie réponse et nous
irons demain les fleurs sont partis j'ai
commandé une couronne
bernard kouchner
[Musique]
la main bonsoir série vous êtes l'homme
politique préféré des français selon un
sondage ipsos le point
lorsqu'il a 64 plus maintenant ah bon le
sondage qui vient de tomber et c'est
françois bayrou alors ça ça va lui faire
une surprise
dans sa déclaration il faut que je le
règle à cbc bon mais c'est branché
directement géré l'udf c'est pour ça il
était à 64 % et pendant l'été vous êtes
passé à 67 % c'est un véritable à grigny
kull d'abord sur les conditions
atmosphériques sûrement et puis
deuxièmement mercier peut-être que ce
que je dis pas complète proco j'en sais
rien d'américain les français apprécient
non sa vie sinon 67% c'est énorme ça
sert à rien enfin c'est gentil de me
lier oui le problème c'est que doit être
présent la république il faut avoir une
base partisane et vous vous êtes plutôt
à un électron libre au ps fait pas 67%
de partisans un bon si jamais vous savez
le ps est un appareil extrêmement
inventif actif on sait jamais ça peut
venir
pierre palmade tu m'entends est ce que
tu deviens pierre écoute moi je trouve
que ça démarre sur les chapeaux de roue
oui de la musique de l'humour c'est tout
ce qu'il fallait pour partir pierre est
ce que tu veux très ce que tu voterais
pour bernard kouchner président de la
république mais j'adore
le mais qu'est ce que tu m'emmerdes avec
ces questions n'est
j'y comprends rien à la politique le
rapport le métier j'adore le
le médecin s'allonge pour lapierre vient
donc au ps fait pas 67 % quand même
bernard kouchner là je ne pense pas mais
hélas il ya hollande qui vous cherche
avec un fusil à pompe êtes au courant
quand même du tout ce à quoi vous êtes
son cauchemar qu'est ce que vous ne
savez pas qui suivait la gauche marc est
ce que vous croyez une seconde que si
ces marques est ce que c'est vrai quand
même sur que non c'est pas vrai mais
c'est marqué à sagem mieux hein c'est
pas marqué c'est vrai alors qu'en
hollande dit je veux entendre le ps
parlé d'une seule voix vous dites oui si
c'est la mienne non jeudi la raison mais
c'est pas demain la veille
ouais bien alors en tous les cas non
c'est vrai qu'avec avec au long de sa
barre de la sélection sa part de gens
attendent et bernard ça a commencé avec
les retraites
vous avez dit que vous étiez d'accord
avec le d'accord j'ai dit que quand on
avait cherché pendant cinq ans 1 mn 10
ans puisque ça a commencé sous le
gouvernement raffarin a réformé les
retraites on n'avait pas se plaindre
quand ça se faisait il avait mis à le
faire nous mêmes un nom alain donc j'ai
dit quelque chose d'essentiel et en même
temps de dérisoire que tout le monde
connaît je n'ai pas dit que j'étais
partisan comme il l'était du projet de
monsieur raffarin
mais réformer les retraites était une
nécessité parce qu'être moins en moins
de gens qui travaillent de plus en plus
à la retraite alors elle a baissé
bon ben voilà d'accord mais on aurait pu
faire mieux surtout si ce qu'on me dit
non on aurait pu le faire mieux surtout
si nous l'avions fait nous-mêmes et
d'ailleurs dans le programme de jospin
s'il avait été élu
et bien il y aurait eu la réforme il y
avait deux comme proposition la réforme
des retraites alors y'a fillon déjà vous
êtes un petit peu d'accord avec lui
s'énerve les socialistes bové vous dites
que c'est du populisme du poujadisme de
la démagogie ce qui énerve aussi
évidemment les gens de gauche je dis que
les réponses sont souvent démagogique
mais que les questions la manière de
s'indigner et de vouloir changer le
monde mais non seulement familière mais
très sympathique simplement quand on
voit son attaque contre l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et qu'on voyait
hier il ya eu un succès formidable grâce
à l'organisation mondiale du commerce
parce qu'on va avoir des génériques pour
combattre le sida dans le tiers-monde
jeudi s'est trompé mais ça n'empêche pas
de trouver non seulement sympathique
quand ils posent ces questions quand il
dit à mon avis des choses tout à fait
anti scientifiques sur les ogm qui sont
là aussi une part de notre avenir
on peut se méfier il faut faire
attention c'est le syndrome de
précaution tout ce qu'on veut d'accord
mais les ogm c'est un peu comme
l'insuline qu'on a fait à part
maintenant l'insuline c'est à partir de
là des modifications génétiques et avant
on en avait pas assez donc faut pas dire
toujours n'importe quoi mais il a des
réponses formidable à d'autres questions
kouchner président coup ridha ben ils
sont tous là non alors on dit quand même
kouchner c'est brice lalonde
c'est mes chances pour qu'il soit y est
presque vous seriez prêt à participer au
gouvernement en disant par raffarin
l'auf en cas de danger nationale
bien sûr pour une union sacrée vous êtes
disponible à brice lalonde s'est quand
même danger national s'est rangé
nationale brisseau plus sérieusement
julien dray a dit on peut pas être à la
fois pour les indiens et pour les
cowboys tiens et ben voilà qu'il mène
loin
ouais voilà qui est une pensée politique
que j'apprécie autant c'est bien ça
résume un tout petit peu tous les
problèmes métaphysiques dont nous avons
à comprendre l'importance et les indiens
et cow-boys mavuba c'est une philosophie
qui ne me convient pas bien
est-ce que
est ce que vous êtes toujours socialiste
oui comme tony blair ou comme pas il
faut prendre 2 le monde a beaucoup
changé je crois que le 11 septembre a
changé encore plus
je pense que la mondialisation ne peut
pas être un problème
rejetée comme forcément hostile et
dommageable et qu'il faut avec l'om c
est le sida par exemple on vient de le
voir apporter une globalisation positive
j'aime bien le mot social mondialisme
plein exemple bien sûr je suis
socialiste
est ce que vous êtes pour la baisse des
impôts de 3 % écoutez je pense que c'est
pas le moment et je pense que ça
avantage des gens qui n'ont pas besoin
d'être avantagés dans un projet d'accord
déroule aussi avec les socialistes
et je pense que on peut pas à la fois
dire qu'on va réformer les urgences dire
qu'on va s'occuper des personnes âgées
en même temps baissé les uns alors ça je
ne comprends pas et de toute façon pour
ce que ça entraînera d'investissements
futurs et de croissance peut-être je ne
crois pas en ce moment beaucoup alors
bernard vous avez remarqué qu'on n'a pas
encore parlé de plus si nos craintes
jusque là je vous en remercie bon voilà
qu'il puise à gauche chez les kouchner
moi je dors à gauche ne l'est elle qui
paye le plus d'impôts elle qui fait les
courses en tout cas l émoi rarement un
pied gauche ailleurs
moi j'ai un métier difficile qui restent
plus longtemps sous la douche
moi tu se savonne pendant des heures moi
qui la savoie
nous avons beaucoup plus applaudis sérum
ou même pas gris voire minizoo rien il
prépare le petit déjeuner bernard moi à
oui oui qui fut soupe au lait des deux
mois qui allume la télé pour garder tout
le monde en parle
christine qui dit le plus de mal
d'ardisson écoute c'est très partagés
les deux se détestent euros non mais ça
ça s'additionne essaies tu l'as sommer
nul tu t'en sors bien
j'accueille maintenant christine ockrent
bonsoir christine ça va je suis très
bien il ya plein de beaux jeunes gens
branchés parmi ces biens et meubles de
m'appeler jeunes gens mais lui il est
bien vraiment surtout qui nous a annoncé
qu'il allait se laver les cheveux jamais
comment ça va très bien bernard ça va
très bien bouge ou encore docteur hugues
bernard bien sûr donc bernard est
toujours en tête dans l'est dans les
sondages un christine et oui numéro un
bernard kouchner tout jeu normal un
incroyable
vous serez peut-être un jour la première
dame de france a déjà les tenues
ridicules voilà drôle je remercie tout
le monde veut avoir un petit pull si ça
s'est terminé
non c'est la guerre alors
doit alors faire une interview première
dame de france
[Musique]
justin concentrez vous vous êtes
peut-être la prochaine première dame ou
en rien adepte
voilà si vous étiez là si vous étiez la
première dame de france qui serait la
seconde à are il n'y en aurait pas
tolérable est ce que ça vous excite ray
de coucher avec un président de la
république
je ne dis pas que j'en ai déjà eu
l'occasion et que j'ai décliné mais ça
ne m'excite ferait pas autrement
est-ce que vous n'auriez pas peur que
bernard deviennent chauve comme tous les
présents dans le public ont coûté non je
trouve que
maintient là aussi une forme
exceptionnelle là aussi la russie comme
en bas il est bien tout ça pour dire
qu'il joue toujours au docteur 1 c
c'est bien dit est ce que on vous verrez
faire de la pub à la tv pour votre mari
avec des judokas et des pièces jaunes
fermer sa g judokas peut-être pas parce
que je me dis allez format serait pas
très aimé des pièces jaunes oui pourquoi
pas et qui sont très utiles saison vous
donneriez votre avis sur la politique du
pays
bien sûr vous oblige auriez votre mari à
faire quoi si vous étiez première dame
de france qu'elle serait là toutes les
semaines déjà
premier truc le cliché exemple la
prolongation des soldes
oui voilà des soldes est maintenant
important qu'est ce que vous changeriez
les rideaux de l'elysée sont les maîtres
non des espaces vides prêt depuis un
certain temps et puis il faut faire
quand même pas besoin d'argent du
contribuable
c'est bien justement c'était ma
prochaine question si vous étiez la
première dame de france
est-ce que vous payeriez vos voyages en
liquide bah non parce que pour les payer
en liquide il faut avoir du liquide et
je n'aurais pas comment as tu vois ce
sont bien ces gens là ils sont bien est
ce qu'ils voudraient vous appeler madame
la présidente
c'est l'usagé je crois oui d'accord ça
serait plus que les cris bien ici là si
ça dépend c'est fini qu'est ce que vous
racontez rien madame bouge pour les
dîners officiels justement j'éviterais
de lui parler de ses filles qui sont
deux jumelles absolument des pestes
d'une personne n'arrive à tenir le tire
la langue aux photographes un hall à la
une propension à piquer il veut imposer
sa vision abondante il arrive pas elle
vient aux défis sont apparemment très
mal et le vin est alors la grand mère
barbara kaki et bien sous tout rapport
prétend avoir beaucoup ri parce que
l'une des petites filles qui est qui qui
a dû monter sur scène à la convention au
avant-hier à dire pour ma grand mère
tchèque chine de seth et qu'il y ait
donc la série que tout le monde adore
elle croit que ça ne se fait qu'entre
gens mariés
uniquement en ville accords bâle sont
sympas les filles oui ça vaut mieux que
le père merci madame la présidente
dans les pâturages monicelli
bonsoir et nous les joies et nous on
sent que pétrolia quelques belles
surprises
bouffier massimo gargia c'est elle que
je préférais à la ferme
j'étais amoureux d'elle ouais et un jour
de ma vie je le regrette pas je suis
très amoureuse de confiance et je sais
de séjour essayé de détruire son fiancé
a saisi jeudi mais pas mais c'est bon
vous avez quand même mis la main en fait
j'étais fou d'amour à la folie elle a
dit elle a dit que ça ne choquait pas
beaucoup il a dit c'est comme si mon
grand père m'avait touché le coeur c'est
ça que tu as dis non c'est pas par
rapport à l'âge c'est plus par rapport à
la relation qu'on avait moi j'aimais
beaucoup massimo jeu bien fait votre
première autobiographie à 24 ans et ça
veut dire qu'il y aura une suite où vous
allez mourir bientôt
non merci j'ai pont une mourir
non non c'est plus que j'avais vraiment
envie de faire ce livre depuis un petit
moment parce que devant même si j'ai que
24 ans j'ai vécu quelques déboires dans
le métier de la chanson notamment avec
mon ancienne maison de disques
donc je voulais faire ce livre mais
c'est vrai que la ferme a permis de le
réaliser parce que personne ne faisait
que forcément confiance avant sur un
livre oui alors ça s'appelle ma revanche
mon innocence
[Rires]
ma revanche mon innocence
et si publié c'était city éditions du
ceva la 4c qui à 16 pages de photos
couleur cette page dans le livre génial
indiqué même cadre que se lit vite
française et la préface et de franck
dubosc qui s'appelle ma revanche pas
innocente
alors la revanche c'est pour ceux qui
usent se sont en quête vous à l'époque
de la ferme ou pour votre ancienne
maison de disques enfin c'est ça un
petit peu mais c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu tout dans livre je détaille un
peu chaque période il ya eu plein de pub
il ya eu mon adolescence c'est un petit
peu plus léger mais j'ai pris une
revanche sur tous mes camarades qui se
moquaient de moi qui disais que j'étais
maigre que j'arriverai à rien
plus tard j'ai prend une revanche sur ma
maison disque avec qui ça s'est pas
toujours bien passé que j'ai dû quitter
ça a été très bon complément de contrat
et la ferme évidemment que j'ai pris ma
revanche parce que personne misé sur moi
parce que c'est vrai ça c'est moi
évidemment le chien en finale 1re fille
donc voilà alors ça c'est la revanche
tant l'innocence et c'est à cause des
photos à poil dans fhm c'est ça non ah
non ça c'est pas d'innocence et c'est
plus une envie j'avais l'innocence et
plus ce qui ressort dans la bouche des
gens quand ils parlent de moi les
lettres que je reçois en plus il ressort
de leurs traits de caractère ce qu'est
ce que tu ne sais pas jean marie c'est
que elle a été étranglée par son cordon
ombilical et qu'une succession en bois
son angoisse et anxiété
[Musique]
je peux dire que ce faux viviane là en
fait c'est génial c'est un tremblement
primates ont étouffé genre à être
enfermés et je pense c'est vrai que ça
ça doit moi je pense que la manière dont
on va avoir des conséquences sur la
manière dont on vit donc sûr j'y crois
evangelii vous racontez votre enfance
donc votre volonté d'être d'être un
garçon parce que c'est vrai quand vous
étiez petit
exiger de votre maman qu'elle nous
appelle simon oui voilà donc c'est dans
le bouquin au prix de location de
chanteuses aussi ce qu'on prend dès
l'âge de 3 ans abon la chiotte aussi à
melun
nous avons réussi
vous chantez quoi capella g10 et ouvre
toutes les chansons je chantais à la
ferme plein plein de chansons douces
lalanne france et la farine et d'enrager
dorsale laura pausini j'adore cette
chanson alors allez-y allait choisir si
longtemps que ça c'est tout mais pence
aidé à ces colis toinon paris my c'est
une connerie comme energy risk ouardi
péter stein qzone kramer à nouveau un
mondial et string 10 poles et athées ou
chine au piano no say comptoir trauma
rétif à la la solitudine
voilà voilà c'est ça a commencé à l'âge
de trois ans eve angeli chantait déjà ça
à l'âge de 3 ans à s'extraire garde vous
racontez votre premier garçon johan un
premier gars mais c'est pas cette
histoire de stylos dans la bouche l'a
jugé pas mais complètement dans la
bouche c'est d'avoir une vie de gaming
c'est à dire que vous appréhendez
tellement mon premier rendez vous
amoureux que mes copines on m'avait dit
si tu es altra que tu sais pas trop
comment faire en train de toi sur un
stylo c'est la même chose j'avais pas
compris pour le bush qu'il fallait
mettre la langue et savait pas comment
poser à 12 ans donc ouais avec des
stylos voilà pour le shopping entraîné
avec donc la première fois que vous
embrasser un garçon c'est à l'âge de 12
ans est la première fois que vous faites
l'amour c'est six ans plus tard c'est
très lent voilà avec michel et vous
n'avez jamais trompé michel donc mais
c'est l'amour qu'avec un seul garçon
dans votre vie à celle là reste qu'avec
17 ans et demi je voulais attendre le
bon moment je suis comme ça je suis très
perfectionniste ne voulais pas que ça se
passe à n'importe qui ça s'est fait de
l'homme avec qui je suis depuis sept ans
et j'espère que ce sera le derby lui en
fait il aimait pas tellement les femmes
jeunes et pour le séduire vous êtes
déguisant vincent mcdoom pratique c'est
ce qu'ils ont dit oui c'est vrai que
j'avais mis des talons j'avais essayé de
me rendre plus femme
parce qu'en fait c'est pas qu'ils
aimaient pas les femmes jeunes c'est
qu'il était sorti avec une femme jeune
et c'était la seule femme qu'il avait
vraiment aimé avant moi et ça a duré
huit ans entre eux et ça c'est fini
parce que c'était son premier rhum a
elle aussi est qu'elle a voulu aller
voir ailleurs au bout de huit ans
moi ça fait sept ans j'espère g passive
la règle mais du coup il s'est dit plus
jamais ça
on l'espère
ne serait ce que par elle raconte cette
histoire a mis du temps quand même un
manque sam
il avait vraiment bien voyez comme une
gamine quand j'avais 17 ans et demi au
départ j'étais en basket je me maquille
à peine vient donc vos galères aussi
pour trouver une maison de 10 vous
finissez par en trouver une
et vous dites cette chose terrible en
parlant de votre ancienne maison 10 vous
dites c'est le même fonctionnement que
les mac et les prostituées qu'ils
avaient senti comme ça ça me ferait du
gore mais deviennent impression d sur le
trottoir vraiment disons de ne plus
faire exactement ce que je voulais c'est
plus dans ce sens là je sens que j'ai
été tenue par une laisse
voilà et dont votive alors vous raconter
la ferme donc massimo gargia qui vous
met la main au cul mais joyeusement
jamais 17
tout le monde était méchant qu'autre
chose et j'en étais la détestais tous
les maux toujours protégé et au début
j'aimais beaucoup massimo c'est qu'elle
chantait qui me jugez pas contrairement
à tous les autres qui me porte à
jugement que ça j'ai toujours ressentir
ça non pas essayer une balitrand alors
c'est une belle ex l'ex de britney c'est
son métier ses appuis ainsi a fait mal
an des jo
la sécurité sociale vous vous dites en
parlant de céline balitran son joli
sourire cache la mâchoire d'un requin et
elle vous trouve beta faut dire la
vérité
l'adie suffisamment n'ai pas inventé
l'eau chaude
c'est ce que j'ai pas aimé en fait c'est
que c'était tout dans le dos devant moi
elle était assez neutre n'a jamais
manifesté d'amour loin des mails étaient
neutres et par derrière c'était vraiment
des trucs pour me faire battre et pour
la minus que beaucoup de gens ont cru au
départ malheureusement que j'étais à moi
pas moi a aussi célébré l'union et toi
connu la moitié et encore oui j'ai pas
tous eu ça c'est évident mais les miens
qui a volé le roy keane a raconté aussi
alors elle par le festival maxime tu
connais maxima bats toi tu rentres tu
rentres tu rentres tu rentres prochains
mois note allait basculer tout à fait
d'accord c'est maximois ils étaient les
plus bas alors vous dites c'est le genre
de mec vous dites c'est le genre de mec
qui fait horreur pharma maxime morel qui
paie a certainement mon nom pour moi
c'est le mec qui fait horreur aux femmes
parce que il est vulgaire
ils respectent pas les flammes
maintenant dans le show business il vous
causent meilleur maintenant vous avez
fait d'affaires mais tout ça non bah
disons que je me rends pas trop compte
parce que je suis je serais même pas
vraiment à paris puisque j'habite en
province je croise des gens qui seraient
plateaux télé mais c'est pas pareil que
si je les connais c'est mieux donc ce
n'est pas du tout ce qu'on pense de moi
dans le métier mais bon comme je sais
que c'est un coup comme ça un coup comme
ça qu'on vous adore un coin vous déteste
alors dans le vie via un truc est très
dense et vos phrases cultes relevé par
emmanuel de brantes sous le nom d'
évangélisme comme débouchés comme le
bouddhisme exactement oui alors ça
s'appelle j'ai dit j'ai pas dis alors
vous allez me dire si vous l'avez dit ou
pas quelqu'un a essayé de traire la
poule ou pas non ça c'est pas moi qui
l'ait dit non c'est une truie c'est une
tondeuse quoi ah ça je les dis parce
qu'en fait je veux dire que c'est
beaucoup de bébés c'est tout on est un
peu dans le trou du cul du monde mais
j'aime ça ça c'est moi
sortir cela m'a donné un spectacle si
vous voulez des fois autant pisser dans
un tonneau je préfère être vivante et en
bonne santé que vivante est malade sa
répétera mais c'est pas moi c'est
pourquoi j'ai le cerveau monté à
l'envers des fois ça fait moi c'est beau
ça ça bien été repris ouais j'ai une
amie qui est décédé mais pas de son
plein gré c'était d'ailleurs c'est la
phrase j'aimerais revoir le montage
global un jour dans ma vie parce que je
comprends pas comment j'ai pu dire cette
conne allait bien j'en ai une ne pas
avoir de micros ne te protège pas des
deux films est apparemment jamais dit
mais pareil je devais de l'état ce bon
ton corps et s'est avancé sur le droit
d'amendement
londres soupçonnent plus bête que si
j'étais brune ça c'est vrai ça ça m'a
bien c'est vrai on dirait que la barre
qu'elle flotte et des brèves de comptoir
et d'en haut c'est quoi cette grosse
chose dans ton pantalon
j'aurais pu le dire non c'est pas moi
c'est sûr certains pépins ce qu'est ce
que tu fais chez les vaches tu n'es pas
une vache ça c'est moi je le ferai
on y est le dis toi que si elle est en
bas avec monnet au dessus ça se joue à
rien c'est ça que j'aime ici là et que
nous on aime et je devais entend garder
c'est formidable on apprécie ses proches
ce n'est pas beau ça mais je ne ronfle
pas je me réveillerai moi même ça c'est
moi est ce que je me suis demandé les
gens qui ronfle comment ils font pour
arriver à dormir siffler j'ai dit aux
copains tard enflé cette nuit ni je sais
pas je dormais on se demande comment ils
arrivent à dormir à globo qui font la
vie c'est court et pourtant une heure
avec toi c'est long c'est très beau mais
c'est trop forcément je vais me laver
les dents parce que j'ai trop faim au
moins ça m'évitera de manger oui parce
que le fumier fume c'est moi d'avoir
côtoyé kaka si longtemps ça m'a donné
des idées au président et celles du
mouton c'est la pro b parce qu'ils se
ressemblent quand même un essai de
pierre dac
c'est ça c'est ça lui vient d'accéder un
chapeau c'est bien mais des chaussures
c'est mieux pour marcher sur camille de
la mer mon rôle
ça va être de réfléchir à voix basse
dans ma tête oui à ce que prévu c'est
que je parle trop semblait fait un pas
sans réfléchir on sent vraiment que je
pense est en deçà c'est pas le triste
tout ça et c'est pour ça que des failles
zero c'est immédiat c'est tout mais
c'est vachement bien en même temps il ya
des choses qui sont très intéressants et
jean marie
si guillaume depardieu
[Musique]
voilà
alors guillaume depardieu acteur de
cinéma tous les matins du monde cible
émouvante
les apprentis césar du meilleur espoir
pola x mart peau d'ange aime ton père
donc régulièrement à l'affiché au cinéma
mais aussi souvent guillaume depardieu à
la une des médias prison ferme pour
revendre d'héroïne en 1993 accident de
moto en 1995 amputation de la jambe en
2003 puis altercation à trouville avec
un pistolet à grenaille neuf mois avec
sursis 5000 euros d'amendé
enfin voilà donc vous êtes un garçon à
la fois qu'on retrouve sur les élevages
des films et à la une est à la une des
médias et c'est pas fini puisque vous
publié chez plon un livre d'entretiens
réalisés avec marc olivier fogiel ton
ami donc un livre qui va faire grand
bruit et qui s'appelle tout donné alors
le livre commence à votre naissance vous
dites je ne suis pas les normales ma
mère a pris un médicament le distilbène
qui a été ensuite interdit à cause de
ses effets secondaires il 300 cas de
jeunes filles qui sont nés stérile et
vous vous avez des malformations
corporelle dites vous des eaux en plus
des trucs comme ça hors des eaux en plus
un cerveau en moi c'est bizarre voilà on
vous parlait aussi de vos rapports avec
votre père vous dites les rapports avec
mon père sont pas normaux non plus il
travaillait tout le temps je le voyais
jamais il n'était pas compatissant de ce
que vous viviez à l'école sert qu'à
l'école on vous emmerdez à cause des
valseuses à cause d'un certain nombre de
films que votre père avait fait est en
fait jamais il vous a dit c'est pas
grave
laisse tomber guillaume c'est des
connards ils n'étaient pas compatissant
non mais c'est même pas ça d'être
compatissant ou pas c'était je sais pas
moi j'avais pas
je savais pas comment réagir vite ça
donc généralement bon ça donnait des
soucis quand je me battais tout le temps
vous dites mon père il m'a eu trop tôt
on sait que c'est samedi sa cellule mais
je confirme mon bain gérard depardieu on
peut s'il veut pas trop vous aider parce
qu'il n'est pas beaucoup et à l'école
non plus donc oui mais c'est touchant
ouais et alors vers 13-14 ans vous
commencez à put rien [ __ ] pour
commencer à fumer du shit à sniffer de
la colle donc c'est quand même assez
jeune vous trouvez vous dit j'étais
devenu quasiment autistes vrai parce que
je n'ai pas du tout le le monde qui
m'entoure est mauvais c'est un peu
ennuyeux au mieux donc me réfugier
surtout dans la musique vous écoutiez
quoi de tout beaucoup de pain quoi
rester l'époque dans le hip hop est là
lui vous preniez le dernier train pour
paris vous allez à paris vous marchiez
dans les rues pendant toute la nuit et
le matin vous preniez le premier train
pour rentrer à bougival faisait quoi
l'année
je déambule et un peu dans pareil quand
je le promets je m'inventais des
identités j'avais les barges été soit
fils de notaire ce fils de
deux militaires soient des trucs
bizarres enfin des trucs comme ça mais
chaque fois j'avais le privilège de
l'anonymat donc c'est comme ça en fait
que je me suis d'abord j'ai compris que
l'on pouvait avec un peu de persuasion
les embobiner tout le monde c'était
assez intéressant et puis ça m'a permis
de découvrir plein d'univers différents
vous disiez jamais que vous étiez le
fils de jarno jamais maintenant sinon
c'est très drôle alors à l'époque vous
êtes 20 d'argent vous n'êtes pas
d'argent votre père non donc vous êtes
gigolo jeu est scellée au grand cours
sinon non j'étais c'est pas pour pas que
pour l'argent c'est par exemple la
première curiosité si bien sûr vous êtes
gigolo pour pour femmes pour hommes
vous commencez avec des femmes mûres
j'aimais bien les fameux mur est donc là
c'était pas tellement pénible non non
c'était plutôt oui c'est bien ce que si
c'était gigolo de luxe j'avais le choix
je choisissais des clients ouais ouais
c'est toujours plus agréable et avec des
mecs aussi nous racontait le premier mec
le premier ouais 14 ans ouais mais j'ai
pas passé grand-chose la première fois
heureuse non non juste préliminaire
ouais et après c'était plus sérieux
c'est arrivé et puis vers 18 ans vous
commencé à mettre le nez dans la poudre
seul a duré six ans 8 j'ai perdu six ans
de ma vie là dedans
ouais mais je le pense mais nous a rien
apporté du tout si mais ça m'a apporté
justement de mais rétrospectivement
parce que je m'en suis sorti mais
parce que je suis costaud quand même non
mais j'en connais tous mes potes de
l'époque sont pas sorties qui sont soit
devenu fou soit ils sont morts alors
vous essayez tout voir ici non seulement
l'héroïne mais aussi l'héroïne mélanger
que la cocaïne ce qu'on appelle
speedball le speedball ensuite vous avez
pris du crack n'aviez pas peur de vomi
quel cerveau non non non j'ai lu quelque
part qu'on utilisait on utilisait de
toute façon juste un dixième de nos
neurones dont toute une existence est
donc bon non mais j'ai géré pas une
approche très quantitative des choses
c'était plutôt c'est plutôt fallait tout
essayer
ouais et puis un jour en revenant de
hollande
vous faites serré vous finissez donc
évidemment en prison vous avez voulu à
votre père d'avoir ici d'intervenir
auprès de nous à la base il à dire vous
auriez préféré finalement qu'il voulait
cela pour empêcher un peu serré que
qu'ils soient pas là du tout qui ne
tiennent pas en plus le discréditer moi
j'ai dire je voulais faire ma peine
jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas de problème
là dessus c'est bien moi je fais ma
peine c'est le même si j'estime que j'ai
rien à [ __ ] là-dedans
justement c'est motivant c'est très
motivant
il est arrêté six ans plus tard vous
êtes arrêté comment tout seul sans rien
non sans méthadone c'est comme ça ouais
solide dur
voilà et puis ensuite vous raconter dans
le bouquin notre amputation suite à
cette maladie nosocomiale
on vous propose soit d'avoir la jambe
raide toute votre vie soit vous faire
amputer ça fait un bon petit parallèle
du vin les mecs qui sont malades dont
les fonds ont tous les mecs qui vont les
autorités pour l'exemple ouais j'ai
testé pour vous ouais alors votre père
vous appelle donc après cette amputation
et vous appelle à l'hôpital il vous dit
c'est vrai comment vous dites ça va très
bien espèce de sarcasmes ça va très bien
j'ai fait un drôle de rêve papa j'étais
entouré de flea toute nue qui me sucer
le moignon oui j'ai vu tout de suite
leur 20ème
il avait des limites au sens de l'humour
vite mon père je l'aimais je le déteste
ont les mêmes raisons son impuissance
non mais c'est toujours pareil de façon
des gens on les aime quand on les aime
vraiment si vous les avez aussi pour
leurs défauts il n'a pas été assez dur
avec vous pensez franchement non je n'en
mets c'est une manière autrement plus
dur aussi de
dire à quelqu'un me démerde toi tu vas
voir la dure quoi moi je trouve que ça
m'a amené vers une liberté qui est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai ça je dois le
concéder je trouve que c'est intéressant
de dire à quelqu'un démerde toi toute
façon tu vas être bien être obligé un
jour te démerder donc mais ce qui est
peut-être un peu tôt découvrez même
qu'il a une fille avec karine syllabes
demi soeur il n'a pas osé vous en parlez
vous la prenez la prison de sa naissance
parce que karine silla appelez votre
père devant vous ouais pour dire que
tout s'était bien passé nous apprenait
sa vie privée par la presse en fait
ouais mais aujourd'hui aussi d'ailleurs
alors parler de votre mère aussi
lisabeth depardieu vous dites qu'ils
sont en instance de divorce depuis 14
ans parce qu'il veut pas lâcher sur le
plan au pognon qu'on ouais mais quel
problème il est milliardaire votre
perdre franchement c'est assez opaque
ouais moi je vois pas ce que vous dites
quand j'étais petit je n'ai pas d'argent
ma mère il veut pas divorcer parce qu'il
veut pas lâcher non mes congés this
qu'inciter c'était beaucoup d'argent
principes d'éducation ma mère et je
trouve ça très bien d'ailleurs
c'est à dire que moi je n'avais pas plus
d'argent que mon meilleur ami est bon
comme si c'était une famille nombreuse
quatre enfants ces milieux bon ouais
pauvres donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très
bien mais non mais mon père dit les pas
du tout pas généreux c'est pas vrai faux
pas on trouve pas qu'on croit ça non
plus et c'est quelqu'un qui a du mal à
filer une pièce par contre si peu de
feeling brics le way
alors quand votre père a lu le bouquin
il nous a dit que certains passages
étaient pas bien qu'ils étaient un non
mais parce qu'il n'avait pas lu il
connaît comment les lycées comme quand
il dit jeudi les scénarios il avait fêté
trois trucs
si vous un dialogue intéressant il le
prend s'il voit un truc et après le lit
mais bon là il avait juste parcouru
trois feuillets il a dit oui et francis
tig m'appelait juste pour me dire qu'il
trouvait ça un pudique
ouais et vous lui avez dit que vous le
trouviez indécent ouais il la lui
maintenant je pense nous est pas une
nouvelle
non ils vous répondent en gala vous
l'avez lu ah bah oui j'ai eu des
nouvelles par greg c'est terrible ce
qu'il dit parce que en fait il dit si ça
l'aide décrire ce bouquin tant mieux
pour lui si ça vous attendez comme
attitude vous voyez attendu
violent franchement je m'en fous ouais
ça me manquait pas dormir c'est pas ça
qui me fait lever le matin
ouais maintenant vous avez fait ce
bouquin vous sentez libéré de quelque
chose moi je sens en tout cas on ne
posera plus les mêmes questions à chaque
fois que je viendrais faire la promo
pour un truc que j'ai fait que j'estime
très bien et qui mérite plus largement
de la tension plutôt que sur ma famille
ou quoi que ce soit comme ça là j'ai
fait aussi pour ça que j'ai trouvé bien
mon intérêt là dedans qu'on fasse plus
chier avec ma famille
d'une part dieu et yann moix
[Musique]
julie depardieu yann moix bonsoir à tous
les deux ans où j'ai rencontré dans un
bar en 1996 tous les deux et vous a dit
je suis sûr qu on travaillera ensemble
oui bon alors moi j'ai rigolé je savais
pas qu'elle était fille depardieu une
blonde que je draguais alors vous avez
dit j'ai aucune admiration pour les gens
qui réussissent
je trouve au contraire beaucoup plus
émouvant ce qu'ils ratent ouais ouais
j'aime bien les gens qui réussissent
mais ça ne veut ça ça me ça ne me fait
rien la réussite est la forme la plus
subtile de l'échec
ouais ou la cgem garde ma fille je viens
noté c'est pour ça qu'ils sont encore
pas si tu veux oui les petites julie je
me fous de plaire l'enjeu c'est de pas
trop me détester oui enfin c'est pas
plaire au plus grand nombre tout ouais
ouais c'est plaire à une petite poignée
à qui on envie de plaire à la rue alors
voulais pas spécialement être une star
abonnés devant mon ambition c'est ça va
très bien là mon ambition c'est d'avoir
des poules
oui j'en aurai 3 je sais déjà les
prénoms je sais tout ce qu'on vous
énoncez mon projet voilà c'est un
dribble pas d'enfant voulait pas
d'enfant bon pas là
ouais après peut-être pas mais poussera
la france vous dites que vous trouver
ridicule et les les actrices qui disent
dans paris match ou dans gala depuis que
j'ai un enfant je vis un rêve
j'essaierai franchement si ça m'arrive
je suis fait un pari donc c'est un pari
idiot si vraiment si je le dis
là je me figure un groupe d'âge je ne
veux pas le dire ça parce que c'est une
évidence on le sait à quoi bon le dire
et je trouve ça ridicule de moi en tout
cas je ne dirais pas même si c'est vrai
c'est pas dans paris match en tout cas
voilà non je ne dirais pas non
même si même si c'est vrai mais tout ça
m'arrache la gueule je le dirai jamais
alors contrairement à votre père votre
frère vous dit vraiment vous défier très
peu la chronique
vous êtes d'une accalmie tude absolument
exemplaire non mais c'est surtout que
non j'ai rien à dire enfin pas au plus
grand nombre
on va on va essayer quand même en
affaires il termine quand on s'appelle
depardieu
[Musique]
quand on s'appelle depardieu us conques
cdpa de chaque fois qu'on ne tombe de
vélo
non moi si je faisais une pub de jeffrey
pour le ménage est ce qu'elle est c'est
un truc auquel je croise les produits
ménagers je pense à eux quand on
s'appelle de perdre us contient bien
l'alcool
ouais ouais cette famille ouais parce
qu'on fait son vin soi même est ce que
quand on s'appelle depardieu on investit
son argent un peu n'importe comment non
pas quand on en a pas est-ce qu'on a
pris facilement des tableaux restaurant
non parce qu'on dit passons nous on a
plus facilement des restaurants
peut-être est-ce qu'on a forcément un
drôle de rire quand on s'appelle
depardieu non regardez le mien est très
correct c'est vrai est ce que quand on
s'appelle depardieu on a parfois envie
de porter un autre nom oh oui oui mais
là c'est un peu tard maintenant j'aurais
dû j'aurais dû le sert à 12 ans comme on
m'avait proposé away qui avait proposé à
mon père
jacquet philippe gilbert
[Musique]
il
et
bonsoir philippe gilbert vous êtes
informaticiens vous vivez à lussac
saint-émilion en gironde
mais depuis de nombreuses années vous
passer plusieurs semaines par an au sri
lanka où vous étiez le jour du tsunami
alors le 26 décembre 2004 vous êtes donc
dans le sud de l'île de ceylan dans un
bungalow vous ai fait construire dans un
village de pêcheurs près de temps gaulle
vous y vivez quatre mois par an il est
amoureux de ces langues est tombé
amoureux de ceylan vous avez des amis
sri lankais notamment m/h parce qu'il
préfère qu'on appelle comme ça et kamina
sa femme ils ont une petite fille aux
syndicats 7 ans qui joue avec votre
petite fille juliette qui a quatre ans
voilà en effet delphine votre fille et
jérôme votre gendre sont venus passer
des vacances à assez lent qu'il ce matin
là votre gendre vous propose d'aller
pêcher mais avant il va faire le marché
attend gaulle avec votre fille les 9
heures vous surveillez les deux
fillettes elles dessinent et là une
touriste qui loue une chambre chez un
mach votre voisin sri lankais est
surprise par une vague que vous
qualifiez de téméraires dans votre livre
et se réfugie dans le jardin et vous
l'aidez à ce moment là vous avez le
sentiment qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ou vous trouvé ça
presque naturel non à ce moment là je
trouve ça tout à fait naturel je suis
habitué à voir la vague de temps en
temps à venir lécher le bord du nil à
l'eau donc on en mangerait pas du tout
surpris pas surpris alors l'eau passe la
clôture du petit jardinet vous réagissez
pas plus à ce moment-là vous rentrez
dans votre bungalow pour pas être
mouillé
hélas le le flot d'eau s'engouffre dans
la pièce en fréquence en tout sur son
passage
dire que la la la porte d'entrée vole en
éclats quoi là vous comprenez qu'il se
passe quelque chose de wil à ce moment
là je prends conscience
même si j'ai pas conscience totale de ce
qui va réellement se passer quelques
secondes après là je commence à
comprendre que ce n'est pas normal
vous comprenez qu'il se passe quelque
chose il ya un deuxième floqué
torrentielles dit vous vous avait de
l'eau jusqu'au cou et vous vous sortez
du du bungalow où vous êtes réfugiés et
dehors la vision est absolument
terrifiante il ya une vague monstrueuse
et vous avez cette image vite j'ai
l'impression d'être comme un égyptien
dans le film les 10 commandements au
moment où la mer rouge se referme quoi
cela vous est submergé par la masse
d'eau c'est ça c'est ça ma première
pensée ça a été tu vas pas souffrir
ouais ouais quand vous voyez un truc
comme ça
là vous pensez que vous allez mourir à
ce moment-là arriver j'en suis tout à
fait persuadé je suis simplement rassuré
à l'idée que
ça va ça va aller très vite que je
souffrais pas pour moi je suis mort
heureusement voilà vous êtes transporté
à 30 mètres de chez vous heureusement
vous accrocher un cocotier et là vous
vous prenez comme ça quoi comme une
espèce de deux bouées de sauvetage c'est
le cas de le dire et vous laisser passer
la vague et vous parvenez à continuer à
respirer donc à survivre tout ça se
passe très très vite
vraiment très très vite et après une
fois que vous êtes accroché
c'est interminable faut que ça cesse
faut que ça cesse et jusqu'à 16 voix la
sécurité la chance de ma fille et de mon
gens c'est qu'ils étaient partis au
marché ce jour là une heure tout à fait
inhabituelle d'habitude ils partent au
marché beaucoup plus tard que cela ils
sont partis et d'habitude ils emmènent
juliette avec eux et là je le redis vu
leur laisser juliette elle est avec 70
tranquille décès je vais les garder
vous demandez donc ou sans eau sans dit
la fille de vos amis sri lankais et
juliette
oui il faut savoir que la vue le
spectacle auquel j'ai assisté je n'ai
pas le moindre doute sur le fait que
juliette et aux 110 soit soit morte ne
peuvent pas avoir je vois la chambre où
elle était il ya un bateau dedans il ya
enfin c'est donc je n'ai plus de doute
sur arte vous vivez depuis avec une
espèce de culpabilité vous vous dites
évidemment j'aurais pu la sauver
alors il ya une chose qu'on prend pas
bien dans le livre quand la vague
arriver ce qu'elle est sur la terrasse
de votre bungalow sur la terrasse du
bengale mhl et une escale dans une pièce
de la maison de votre voisin une dizaine
de mètres derrière moi même pas
enfin ivan béton une dizaine de mètres
derrière moi dans une dans une chambre
une chambre d'hôte quoi si vous voyez un
joue avec sa petite copine de samedi et
a dit m non a dit m vous l'aviez sous
les yeux à ce moment là j'avais aucune
raison à ce moment là j'ai avant que la
vague arrive de les surveiller de très
près c'est un endroit très très très en
sécurité
c'est vraiment sincères véritables
paradis donc aucune raison de les
surveiller après que d'habitude
par contre après entre le moment où la
vague m'est arrivé dessus le moment je
me suis retrouvé trente mètres plus loin
avec l'accroché comme un conte aux
cocotiers
je peux même pas dire que j'ai pensé à
ce moment là aussi à julien je peux le
temps j'ai pas vu je pense à rien
strictement rien maintenant il me reste
un truc terrible affaire c'est
d'annoncer ça m'a fait de revenir si
vous voulez d'aller vers eux et de
d'affronter le regard de ma fille qui va
me voir arriver moi vivant tout seul
sans sa fille l'a effectivement voulais
retrouver sur le marché de temps gaulle
ils sont même pas mouillé évidemment
puisque c'est à des kilomètres de là
vous dit jamais je n'oublierai le cri de
delphine qui dément insoutenable oui
rien d'autre à rajouter ça m'a marqué
pour le restant de mes jours
alors ensuite vous allez dans un hôtel
qui est situé à 7 km de temps gaulle sur
les hauteurs un hôtel qui s'appelle eva
lanka et là vous êtes choqués parce
qu'en fait les touristes évidemment ils
savent pas ce qui s'est passé donc ils
profitent de la journée de vacances
comme si de rien n'était et nous on
arrive là on fait encore que ma fille et
mon gendre était correctement habillés
mais en ce qui me concerne j'étais en
loques en sang ça fait un drôle d'effet
de de voir qu'il ya des gens qui ont pu
ne pas se rendre compte du tout de ce
qui s'était passé
voyez une personne qui concerne est
quand même celle n devynck de lci qui
qu'il a avec son compagnon emmanuel
carrère l'écrivain oui et elle vous
parle et vous témoigner sur lci de ce
qui s'est passé en fait ce jour là
oui et ça ça a été le départ de tout ça
a été
si j'ose utiliser des mots comme ça dans
notre situation ça a été une chance
inouïe une chance inouïe parce que si
vous voulez il est évident qu'on aurait
de toute façon aider les très proches
amis de ne serait-ce qu de cette sortie
de ça mais là le fait que j'ai été par
chance le premier à témoigner
ça a tout de suite amené les médias vers
nous quand on est rentré en france
bon c'est pas trop trop mon style de
jouer avec ça mais là je crois que
j'avais pas le choix mais il aurait
fallu que je sois très con pour ne pas
jouer à ce jeu donc on a laissé les
invite le paraître dans paris match
on a même été jusqu'à accepter qu'une
photo de juliette 70 soit diffusé
c'était pas de gaieté de coeur mais je
crois que c'était le seul moyen pour
qu'on récolte la somme maximale nous
permettant d'aider non plus une deux
trois familles mais quelque 50 ou 100
familles puisque c'était notre objectif
à partir de ce moment là alors ce que
vous découvrez à ce moment là c'est
qu'il est impossible de rapatrier le
corps de votre petite fille juliette
pour la faire incinérer en france c'est
purement interdite il faut le faire au
sri lanka et un jour vous irez jeter les
cendres de juliette dans un jardin
botanique à kandy près d'un massif de
bougainvilliers voilà alors là vous
commencez avec votre gendre jérôme a
échafaudé une association pour aider les
habitants de ce petit village de
pêcheurs vous inventer ce qu'on appelle
le kit de nécessité alors c'est quoi
exactement savez ça consiste en d'abord
on s'improvise 1 on a jamais fait la
même manière
donc vous arrivez avec un trac pas
possible en vous demandant si
vous allez être à la hauteur parce que
c'est quand même pas le droit de se
planter
et puis vous allez à l'essentiel
vous distribuez des feuilles de papier
dans le village et vous dites aux gens
en fait vous vous prenez les tabs besoin
de quoi ouais la commande
voilà tu as besoin de quoi on n'est pas
les blancs sauveur venant à la rescousse
c'est non là on se fait tout petit de
quoi tu as besoin et on s'aperçoit ça va
très vite c'est en quelques jours les
besoins sont toujours les mêmes
un lit un matelas sas a pris une
importance terrible après vous verrez un
moustiquaire des ustensiles de cuisine à
la bullet il ya des besoins
enfin c'est vraiment élémentaire leur
rendre leur dignité
mais voilà attention la plupart des
familles non non non plus de toi non
plus deux mais au delà du fait qu'elle
n'ait plus de toit et plus de maison
elle mange dans des feuilles de journaux
et les enfants dorment par terre sur les
ruines des maisons et ça je l' ai vu de
mes yeux vu là vous vous dites ya
urgence
alors vous cherchez pas à vous organiser
alors soit vous partez au quart de tour
vous foncez alors vous fait des bêtises
vous mettez quatre jours à équiper 10
familles parce que vous pensez qu'il
faut faire le tour des commerçants etc
et après on devient un petit peu moins
bête on se dit bon on va s'organiser on
va distribuer les tickets aux gens ils
vont aller eux-mêmes dans les boutiques
tout ça se met en ordre
bon il faut reconnaître aussi qu'on a là
affaire à un peuple
qui n'a pas du tout la mentalité des
peuples occidentaux
on est sur des gens qui sont face à ce
malheur d'une dignité déjà absolue
extrêmement réservé padilla pas de
panique il ya une scène de panique
alors que faut pas oublier que là on est
au bout du bout de la première semaine
on sait qu'on va avoir 700 familles à
l'équipe et on accouche là ça y est on
le sait on va mal vous voir on a mis une
frontière si vous voulez medac et tire
mais c'est horrible déjà ça cette
frontière car il veut dire bats toi tu
étais petit l'autre côté de la route tu
rentres pas dans le monde
voilà vous vous mettez au boulot avec
jérôme pour essayer de les aider est en
revanche pas de trace de ong vous dit où
sont les dons où sont les 20 tonnes de
médicaments a mené dans sept airbus 310
a coûté trois cent mille euros pour la
pour acheminer les dons vous voyez rien
voyez des 4,4 flamboyant dites vous des
4 4 9 de la croix-rouge et vous dites
qu'une de ses voitures vous permettrait
avoue enfin en tous les cas aux gens du
sri lanka de reconstruire sans maison
dans l'avion on se
on s'inquiétait de savoir comment on
allait pouvoir nous tous petits lardons
et granité pétillent à s'entendre avec
toutes ces ong sur place
ouais parce que comme vous on a entendu
que il y avait
des dons faramineux que toutes les ong
étaient là bas que se dit comment on va
trouver notre place la has a pas été
difficile on était là un seul ouais on
était tout seul quand je suis arrivé au
début février on était tout seul quand
juste quand mon gendre est parti fin
avril absolument personne
c'est incroyable parce que la france a
envoyé 190 millions d'euros
il paraît que l'argent est placé dans
les sicav monétaires comme ça c'est un
véritable scandale d'un accord quand je
lis moi dans le parisien sélectionné t
il lui même qui le dit que il a pour les
patrons de la croix rouge après avoir
été patron de la canicule
et voilà qu'il a 100 millions de dons et
à aujourd'hui ils ont dépensé 7 1
il ya quand même quelque chose
d'absolument obscènes à détourner de
cette façon l'argent que les gens ont
donné pour le sri lanka la thaïlande la
visite c'est absolument scandaleux
oui il ya 7 % des sommes qui ont été
données au sri lankais le reste ils
n'ont pas vu voilà moi je ne remets pas
en cause la bonne foi de ces gens je dis
c'est de la bêtise mais en même temps
c'est tout à fait scandaleux
donc il faut demander des comptes à la
croix rouge du sur et bien on va appeler
le docteur robert sebag
[Musique]
il
non
bonsoir alors cet administrateur
national la croix-rouge votre fonction
en fait c'est de faire la somme des dons
reçus de savoir comment l'argent est
dépensé
les missions sur le terrain c'est moins
votre truc qu'on fasse qu'un vous qui
gérait le pognon j'en ai fait une voie
là alors où est l'argent ou et le pognon
alors ce que ce que je peux vous assuré
il ya une partie de l'argent qui a été
dépensé et il ya il ya une programmation
on a signé sans en ce qui vous concerne
en désaccord il ya 70 ans région non
mais vous dit combien cette sur 107 sur
100 millions alors oui la boue sur les
93 millions
il ya 70 millions d'euros qui sont
engagés aujourd'hui il ya mille maisons
deux hôpitaux au sri lanka en indonésie
à l'approvisionnement en eau qui se fait
dans la région d'ankara dans la région
dans la région de galles vous le savez
il faut des bureaux il faut une
logistique en indonésie on a pu plus de
50 personnes qui sont sur place
il ya eu le tremblement de terre sur
l'île niasse on a été tout de suite là
on a remis 10 litres d'eau par personne
et par jour 160 mille litres d'eau à
filtrer il fallait transporter le
matériel
alors l'argent il est pas dépenser en
immédiat il est pas dépenser comme sale
argent et pourquoi
mais mes pensées sexistes death quoi
vous avez les autres il vous faut des
récipiendaires
il faut des gens de confiance vous
pouvez pas distribuer l'argent à
n'importe qui vous connaissez ce pays
comme la région dans le coup que
philippe gilbert mais pourquoi est ce
que les braves pêcheurs qui ont eu tout
détruit on leur dit pas à chacun on vous
donne c'est pas moi dix mille dollars
pour acheter un bateau pour acheter on
est en train ce qu'on a jamais fait si
vous voulez d'avoir des partenaires
locaux de l'association là on vérifie
qu'elle est entre mes mails mais c'est
en revenant au temps des choses comme ça
que nous avons c'est bien parce que
votre discours au moins il est honnête
vous vous êtes en train de faire un
constat d'échec
c'est incroyable c'est un jeu retour je
vais retourner mois de juillet au sri
lanka à côté de medhatiyah il va en jeu
rien d'un héros qui voudront pas
vraiment chez d'en devenir le jour nous
faudrait alors que 300
mignon excusez moi à dr hennet attendez
attendez il est en question il n'est pas
question de mettre ici en doute
l'efficacité est là et la qualité de la
croix rouge c'est pas du tout notre
propos efficacité un peu comme
efficacement tous les cas la croix rouge
a fait ses preuves depuis depuis plus
d'un siècle moi ce que je veux dire ce
que je veux dire simplement voilà ce que
je disais docteur ce que dit philippe
gilbert il dit voilà il dit moi je vais
retourner parce que c'est un amoureux de
s'élancer plus qu'un touriste c'est un
mec a construit une baraque la base
gilbert bon on qui va aller là bas il va
voir ces gens qui vont continuer à
bouffer dans des comédies dans des
journaux à dormir sur des ruines
alors que vous vous avez fait pas des
millions et des millions d'euros sur des
placées en sicav monétaires c'est ça qui
concerne un sujet pareil
vraiment je veux pas polémiquer surtout
pas avec vous ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on a repéré un certain nombre
d'associations locales vous même je vous
le dis je le dis je le dis devant tout
le monde
je veux dire nous sommes tout à fait
prêts sur votre association parce que
vous êtes quelqu'un de confiance de
votre village vous avez vécu vous avez
construit à financer un projet je le dis
c'est pas c'est pas le souffle jadis
prenant vous avez raison il faut de
l'argent jeu important mais aussi très
très long vous être submergé excusez-moi
des mauvais jeux de mots par la
bureaucratie quoi mais la bureaucratie
locale aussi la bureaucratie locale
faire des virements d'argent locaux à
voir les dédouanements vous savez que
même sur des médicaments d d d d d
ddd filtreurs d'eau on doit à la douane
on doit payer un certain nombre de taxes
tout est contrôlé vous pouvez par brûler
pour une énorme face à une catastrophe
comme si vous envoyez des églises par la
nôtre des petites équipes de revient du
générique vous savez que je disais moins
les jeunes quand vous allez arriver à
l'aéroport
vous allez vous n'allez pas dire que
vous êtes une région solidaire vous êtes
touristes ça nous permettait de rentrer
tranquillement dans le pays si jamais
vous disiez ong et vous bloquer et vous
restiez quinze jours à colombo
je vienne où on passait comme touristes
on a ouvert un compte en banque tout de
suite là bas on fait on faisait virer
l'argent la barre les faits on hamm est
fonte et des équipes avec des stries
donc payer mais je sais j'en limites
avec tout l'argent manager et même neige
en biélorussie un exemple en mairie ils
roupies par jour à chaque c'est
l'enquêté
van cachée décevant je vous dis bien
encore nous noie là nous on a fait je
m'arrête ici les gens compte de nos
jours c'est toujours toujours
rapidement secouru n'entend cantons sur
les âges s'est enfoncé de l'inquiétude
on se demande toujours où va le pognon
la croix rouge tout humain contient
justement j'en ai je vous hais il faut
aussi jugé les programmes qu'ils ont
faits qui ont lieu aujourd'hui au sri
lanka
vous n'êtes pas tomber sur les villages
mais je le dis et je le répète votre
association mais non écoutez vous
connaissez comme moi le sri lanka
la cote était non je veux dire vous vous
pas remettre en question on va
construire 1000 maisons on va construire
trois centres hospitaliers
il ya 25 ans on va vous nommer une
maison avec les gens on est aussi en
indonésie on est aussi le pays où il ya
eu personnes en somalie parce que la
somalie a été touché au rein n'a pas par
là on parle pas des sommets
non mais cette urgence de lits des
matelas ces deux moustiquaires
aujourd'hui pour résumer la situation
rend 6 où tu vas sa conversion groupé
avec l'argenterie un tour vous ne payez
pas des gens te montre est d'accord pour
payer et engager des gens payés la mise
en chômage
riscle et je vous avais effectivement
dans le poujadisme café malheureusement
ça du tout et pendant ce temps là ce
sont les banques qui sont du pognon avec
l'argent qui est dessus mais sur les
comptes
les sicav monétaires ce rapport du
pognon pas du tout et pas vous pouvez
pas vous pouvez pas déverser vous pouvez
pas déverser sur un pays 25 millions
d'euros
comme ça tout d'un coup donc tout
l'argent je peux vous assurer c'est de
l'argent l'argent l'argent qui est
l'argent qui n'est pas dépensé tous les
intérêts sont reversés au programme asie
vous savez très bien que les période de
reconstruction
ça va durer longtemps encore fallait
cause c'était le but
or au bout d'chou je vous dis c'est pas
qu'on vous connaissez un rouge mais j'en
mets jugé minable
non mais mais mais là je ne peux pas non
plus il ya des volontaires c'est pas un
problème d'organisation des morts mais
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi
on a aussi des comptes à rendre parle
pas déjà un serveur aimait bien je suis
d'accord mais quand vous avez des
partenaires comme monsieur on est tout à
fait prêt je le redis à aider
spécifiquement son village mais s'est
passé ça s'est relancé dans mes lui
avoir d'effet c'est pas nouveau mais la
part où j'avais une vision d'ensemble
même plus et bien sûr concrètes pour que
quelqu'un vous êtes ça sert à rien c'est
bien gentil de dire ça la maintenance
sans me retourner
mais c'est pas ça c'est une règle aux
fonderies hier soir des deux villages
réponse année vous pour avoir des
témoins de vitesse
aussi d
refuser d'aider tout le monde on
pourrait on pourrait avoir ici en face
des villageois dans lesquels nous sommes
présents
on a fait des milliers d'étrangers
sperme et quelques rires et merci à la
3e bonne blague mais heureusement j'ai
la gêne il ya l'organisation avait
chassé qu'est-ce que cas c'est ce que
vous parce que c'est ça qui est
important
vous vous habiter là-bas vous y allez
plusieurs mois par an vous encore une
fois vraiment sri lankais d'esprit
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
faire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je
pense qu'il faut faire moi je crois que
je viens de m'exprimer suffisamment sur
le sujet jeu est tout simplement il faut
que l'argent qui aujourd'hui d'or dans
des banques soient utilisées d'une façon
ou d'une autre alors c'est comme le dit
fort justement laurent ruquier s'est par
exemple payer les chômeurs en france et
tant pis si on fait du poujadisme parce
que là s'il ya dix ou quinze ans plus
bon ou tout simplement le distribuer il
y en a pas besoin d'autant que vous en
avez des petites associations comme nous
qui vont au moins essayer de faire
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire de ramener très
vite ces villages a dit parce que quand
vous dites mon village il votre village
je peux assurer que j'ai fait la route
de colombo à je sais où vous étiez vous
étiez plutôt sur la côte est d'accord
bien à pic alors voilà voilà
mais toute la côte qui est là je peux
vous dire que les gens n'ont pas été
aidé du tout sert toute la côte entre
colombo et thorgal est en mode total n'a
pas été aidé du tout gaulle par exemple
sap a été donc c'est qu' à ce qui a été
fait non c'est dans ces villes c'est la
plupart du temps on a travaillé sur le
plan hôpitaux
voilà il ya eu beaucoup de choses de
faites donc ça je remets pas ça en
question mais c'est pas parce qu'on
construit un hôpital qu'il faut laisser
les gens dans la merde aux abords de
l'heure au bord de l'eau vous voyez bon
voila et et surtout ce qui me choque
c'est que c'est des sommes faramineuses
dont on entend parler alors que nous
avec cent mille euros c'est une goutte
d'eau on a redonné à 700 familles la
dignité élémentaire dont ils avaient
besoin
ainsi les emails
[Musique]
gérard géron soirée puisque tu penses
je vais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gérard énorme carrière je peux pas dire
c'est vrai alors qu'est victoria à
victoriaville bien victoria sait vous
donc 25 ans 1 m 70 63 kg 95 ces belles
poitrines jolie poitrine jets d'affaires
à 13 tirs pour tous les types de croix
qui excelle seynois axel bonsoir 23 ans
1 m 76 66 kg 80 c'est comment tu sais
j'ai le coup d'oeil
mais c'est incroyable 85 b j -l 24 ans
donc c'est vous évidemment un mètre 68
57 kg combien 85 c non 90 b c'est pareil
cd j'ai fait un stage en super fan va
commencer par les origines on va faire
tous les mensurations mais tu donnes pas
les autres mensurations non non vous
êtes de quelle origine française
française soit là et vous colombienne
et vous
mais il ya cette voix c'est à dire gg
vous avez pris conscience à quel âge que
vous étiez une femme dans la tête
[Musique]
je pense que c'est toi t'as pas eu le
courage la différence avec 4 gigas a pas
eu le courage d'aller jusqu'au bout
exactement intéresser un garçon je suis
une femme était restée là
et ta voix de deux garçons crooneuse 200
une clause simon gagné 2,6 alors vous à
quel âge j'ai pris conscience que vous
étiez un jeune très jeune quel âge avait
vrai dire on vers 5-6 ans j'aimais bien
six ans et vous compreniez pas pourquoi
vous avez été un garçon âgé comme modèle
un trophée mannequin que j'adorais et
kavala j'ai voulu lui ressemble et nous
rassemble
c'était pendant l'adolescence ouais les
premiers émois way temps comprend
l'amour vous aviez des érections pour
les garçons et pas pour des filles en
fait c'est ça non mais oui oui un chat
est un chat
ça ne sera pas coupée au montage s'il
attendait les enfants ont la garde
regarde bien quelles ont été les
réactions de vos parents très bien parce
que bas depuis l'âge de 5 ans justement
nommé déguisé en fait un mort idées dans
la déguiser et ma mère je m'amusais à
boucan avec ma soeur est d'accord donc
j'ai eu des parents complices oui et
vous quelles ont été les réactions de
vos parents quand vous avez dit maman je
suis une fille quoi bel été je pense un
peu choqué parce que bon elle a mis au
monde un garçon et puis elle m'a quand
même à elle m'a quand même donné sa
bénédiction
c'était quoi la réaction de paris
c'était un peu difficile au début mais
après c'était un jab n.mamère gilles map
est gisèle problème l'appétit de nos
filles ma belle mère et fille delphine
aussi est-ce que vous avez déjà eu à
l'époque vous étiez garçon garçon est ce
que vous avez eu des expériences avec
des filles manon vous n'ont jamais fait
l'amour avec une fille non et vous ces
cas n'ont jamais jamais jamais c'est
dégueulasse
et alors comment ça se passe et que les
cartes sont aujourd'hui comme toi
ga mais quand tu rencontres un garçon
est ce que tu lui dis voilà j'ai l'air
d'être une fille mais en fait à mes mots
ont un sens oui même quand même super
moore et commence à sérieusement vous
dit vous dit aux garçons vous comme on
chez elle oui fort belle manière puisque
nous lâcher un garçon qua non à une
transaction entre filles super je suis
sur un genre y'a pas de problème
est ce que c'est ce que j'ose séparation
quand est ce que vous allez faire
l'opération pour devenir vraiment des
filles sérieusement c'est à dire que là
c'est pas la priorité
ah bon pourquoi pas un défaut by vous
avez vraiment envie de le faire oui bah
sinon serait sympa on vous appelle avec
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ça dépend
j'ai eu des intrus d'oreille ce qu'on
peut dire que votre sexe vous gêne voilà
c'est comme ça vous gêne le news line
je viens ici dit gérard darmon d'autres
non mais c'est vrai que terry pourrait
trouver un soutien gorge a sorti un slip
rouge a salué freins possibles les
détails donc tuer non seulement c'est
une technique avoir illégalement
alors est-ce que tout s'aggrave de
souche et les centres se gratter des
couilles
[Applaudissements]
si ces quelques épisodes seulement tu
préfères te toucher ça je sais pas
disons mais c'est vrai toi aussi oui
c'est humain si tu m'as tout aussi se
détendre et veille à les mater
ça vous arrive encore de vous bourrer la
gueule avec des potes regarder des
matchs de foot à la télé en buvant de la
bière
j'aime bien quand même te garder ça
l'est mais la petite érection du matin
ça reste non j'ai plus non encore est ce
que vous laissez encore par exemple les
chaussettes traîner dans le salon comme
un mec non sans jamais arriver
jamais jamais donc je viens vous jeu non
plus si elle était composée de toilette
comme ces demoiselles
vous essayez quand tu vas tu vois pas
tout garder tout ça je garde tout
c'est ce qui m'embête ans qui m'embête
un genre ce qui m'embête c'est le regard
de volga parce que géant directement
veulent à regarder je suis pas en train
de te tromper je vous en veux parce que
je viens d'apprendre que vous laissez
traîner vos chaussettes
je suis parvenu à me coeur donné tu
verras c'est moi qu'est ce que je suis
c'est là la conseillère artistique de
l'émission frédéric arnould est-ce que
je suis un garçon désordonnée merci bien
alors sérieusement est-ce que parce que
l'homme est ce que l'homme qui est en
vous parce qu'il ya toujours une partie
damman vous est ce que l'homme qui est
en vous
s'énerve quand vous mettez deux heures à
vous préparer bah oui un moment où tu as
envie de sortir toi il attend nos 3 la
réponse naturelle
c'est d'ailleurs quand la flamme se
prépare à prendre
et alors est ce que la femme qui est en
vous parce que c'est une dimension femme
s'énerve quand par exemple vous regarder
du foot à la télé ça dépend si les
joueurs de foot sambo a bâti en bonnes
réponses
enfin bonne réponse est-ce que l'homme
qui est en vous adore le film porno oui
rotana miracle de toi même tu as
vraiment lui qui n'aime pas le sexe
ouais moi et maintenant on passe au
musée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher le
zapper conserver son hardiman sont bons
même la qualité
[Musique]
à manama
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'art dima je
sais que bon nombre d'entre vous seront
très étonné de voir mon visage ainsi
masqué parce qu'en termes professionnels
nous nommons une mosaïque mais d'un
commun accord avec la direction de la
chaîne
nous avons décidé de lutter contre cette
mise en valeur excessive des vedettes de
télévision que l'on dénonce à juste
titre dans vos journaux
je crois que face à cette scandaleuse
tarification il était temps de réagir
halte au nombrilisme hardy matt l'a fait
j'ai vraiment
je vais maintenant vous rappeler les
principes de mon émission
pendant un peu plus d'une heure vous
allez voir des documents exceptionnels
que j'ai choisis pour vous j'espère
qu'ils seront vous plaire car comme on
vous l'a assez répété si vous zappez je
suis viré je sais je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous verrez la chose sont trop
de regrets notamment monsieur georges
chossat de nantes
melia ap vous connaissez tous ap
je sais les français aiment beaucoup les
animaux
moi aussi un bon petit japonais il est
joli hein ah il est très joli très bien
mais très bientôt à l'été un vraiment
petit à pune vous avez compris s'il a
redit ma descente sous de 15%
je bute le club s'est vu un bon petit
zappe
alors soyez gentils et regardez mon
émission jusqu'à la fin où j'ai avec moi
le professeur rollin bon sens pour
beaucoup
suit une remarque mettez-y un petit peu
plus de nerfs vous avez l'air à moitié
endormi ce soir vous savez pour faire de
l'audimat il faut que ça swingue
ouais jean-pierre mais téléspectateur
moyen alors comment ça va bien très bien
si je le peux ah oui oui toujours fidèle
qui rien mais pourtant ça a été
difficile parce que maintenant on est
assez demandée avec jean-pierre on a
vraiment fait des pieds et des mains
pour se libérer enfin bon merci d'être
là je veux pas
ok rival
bravo jeudi un écoute même moi qui étais
au courant j'ai cru presque ça mettrait
la série formidable un bien foutu grand
professionnel il a exercé comme plateau
ça marche toujours
quand l audience celle ci
oui le petit à petit de tardi sont l'ins
que je raconte que je dise de mots pour
voir carla des émissions comme ça tout
seul de ses 9 août dans la voix la
télévision c'est pas étonnant qu'on
parte en brioche non mais c'est pas vrai
bru type high museum sa clémence poesy
dont il sera acquitté en plus vous allez
laisser cette gestuelle tube i'm not
track c'est moi qui devrait la voir son
go sport dont la tête je te le dis moi
c'est vrai que quelque part tu ferais
rien c'est insulter sans rien des très
bons pour nous pouvons vous engueuler
plus l'audiencement avant et madame sert
de vous savez qu'il le faut est le chien
est ce que les chiens ça me dégoûte
j'aimerais vu les guidages quel chien ça
pue le ch comme toi ça me choque de
charles pas depuis pas évident la
vieille dame est question c'est surtout
vous dire un truc ça pète le clan des
meubles j'ai déjà culte des morts tas
parce que j'ai deux buts et moi aussi
moi je vous dis pas dans la gueule jédir
connaît
nous
pour moi c'est bon pour l'audience parce
qu'elle va pas rater la wii mais thierry
cela valait la peine à manger c'est tout
à fait bon pour l'audience il faut
souffrir un peu avant pour faire de
l'audience là c'est bon série s il va
pas vous n'avez pas l'air dans votre
assiette la suite
je pensais à la villa on est enfermé
dans un studio tous les samedis soirs ge
est pas contre vous mais la vie est
courte série maintenant mais la cie se
trouve je pense ça se trouve c'est en
train de rater un truc truc super au
bistrot du coin puis je suis là moi ça
me laisse un peu flipper quoi je
pourrais je sais pas il pourrait se
passer des trucs dans la rue prend bien
j'y vais non non non tu rigoles non ça
ne se fait pas écouté j'ai réussi vous
avez besoin de vous dégourdir les jambes
vous pouvez quand même patienter une
heure le temps de finir cette émission
vous avez cent soixante sept heures dans
la semaine pour vous promener
maintenant j'y vais non franchement
dangereux après la non à l'egypte
tu as pris c'est pas raisonnable écouter
thury allons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
elle
[Musique]
au café souplet joseph boire un café sur
wii ça va [ __ ] j'y tiens dix ans quand
même mais c'est excitant mais je suis
tjrs ardisson merde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ouais ça va bien je me réveille
complètement ça fait une semaine que
j'étais là et maintenant on applaudit
consistance
aussi francis dolan bonsoir francis
comment se passe cette tournée à travers
la france oui il se passe bien
elle se base
terry l'argument est descendu en dessous
de la barre des 15%
sans rancune
ap on voit rien de personnel
zap a tué là nous à pune tulle à dieu
soit loué
je vous montrais un truc qui va vous il
va vous plaire c'est plus intello c'est
une interview de jacques derrida
enfin vous allez voir comment vous
pensez aujourd'hui le rapport entre
philosophie littérature et à ce que
finalement les parcours qui ont été les
vôtres et dans la philosophie et dans la
littérature ne vous conduisent pas à
penser que l'écriture littéraire
finalement résout des problèmes que la
philosophie pose chance d'être capable
de les résoudre
j'essaie de rassembler là c'est tout
simple l'elysée des références
essentielles littéraire qui sont les
vôtres et quand on fait cette
bibliothèque on se dit qu'elle va être
quelque chose en commun et c'est sur
quelque chose en commun que tu voudrais
vous entendre artaud bataille joyce
blanchot ses précédents au fond qu'est
ce qui rassemble ces écrivains qu'est-ce
qu'il fait leur pourquoi sont-ils dans
votre panthéon
on sait certainement pas un panthéon
d'abord 7,7 s'est ouvert ensuite
j'hésite à répondre à cette question là
parce que si je répondais je dirais
voilà ses talents ont quelque chose en
commun et ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
qu'il entend comme thierry très bonne
surprise parce que ce document est très
intellectuel et pourtant le la courbe
n'a pas cessé de monter comme quoi
contrairement à une idée reçue bien la
culture ça peut aussi payer sur le
service public c'est formidable oui
thierry oui faites votre bon soir
normalement thierry puisque tout est
normal hein pas vrai les amis
mais vous êtes messieurs bonsoir
bienvenue austin home n'a pas bon hardy
matt avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
je voudrais vous dire que comme toute
émission qui se respecte
nous allons vous offrir des cadeaux des
tas de cadeaux
ce soir vous allez vous partager son
téléviseur team sanya télé commande
vocale pour gagner il suffit d'appeler
le 47 28 02 47 pour élire votre télé
potiche préféré parmi les cas que nous
allons vous présenter tout au long de
l'émission les 100 premiers gagneront
donc un téléviseur tits hayate les
commandes vocales
les 1000 suivants recevront la cassette
du film al khaliq de spike lee qui sort
cette semaine sur vos écrans c'est quel
film qui sort cette semaine thierry
balkanique
[Applaudissements]
votre votre nom noreen prénom maureen à
pardon c'est d'or votre âge n 2 ans
profession touristes à paris tourista
barelwis et vous l'êtes potiche chez
nous oui ça vous intéresse
oui pourquoi pas peut-être petitjean
d'autres endroits autant de potiche à la
télé est-ce que vous lui oui mais à la
télévision en direct devant les caméras
s'est dit pour lui qu'il caméra toutes
ces caméras là
oui oui oui c'est d'accord
oui professeur sall est d'accord thierry
alet d'accord
on va écouter mettez vous habitez du
président laura ramsey de
présélectionner merci et maintenant
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais vous
montrer des images absolument incroyable
d'un mais qu'est ce qui m'arrive la
vérité bloqué dans la mémoire de trappes
gauche à la dégager
bloqué dans quoi cette fois c'est
compliqué c'est lé défi certes on l'a
surtout qu'à côté marrant toi t'as vu la
gueule que j'ai en plus un [ __ ] ouais
ces trucs là ça se bouge tout le temps
un coup de pompe et 5 passes aïe aïe ça
a l'air sérieux qu'est ce qu'on fait
faut envoyer la bécane ces opex et les
mecs gentils je vais quand même pas y
passer la nuit un [ __ ] t'as vu ma
gueule je sais pas moi démerdez vous
appelez la fêter o'neill et
[Musique]
professeur chutes d'audiences
catastrophiques tard et maintenant le
troisième invité claire chazal
est-ce que ça t'embête quand on
t'appelle mais médéa est ce que ça
t'embête plus qu'avant c'est vrai que
lorsque tu prends l'avion maintenant tu
gardes les factures et pourquoi tu
ferais pas comme christine ockrent ou
anne sinclair t'épouserais pas un
ministère très bien merci
ces messieurs bonsoir bienvenue au
studio hardy matt je vous interromps il
y a un petit problème pour l'émission de
ce soir je vous dis tout de suite c'est
de ma faute
la semaine dernière samedi dernier vous
avez dit je m'en branle
vous vous en souvenez grossièreté que
j'ai été obligé de sanctionner puisque
nous sommes sur le service public par un
extrait du documentaire culturel veut ni
citer des dogues rhin mais et c'est là
mon erreur je vous en ai mis 13 secondes
en me fiant aux barèmes 92 j'avais eu
les yeux
or j'ai reçu entre temps le barème 93
qui lui est de 15 secondes pour que m'en
branle
il ya par conséquent un reliquat de deux
secondes de venise qu'il faudra diffusé
à un moment ou un autre de l'émotion
c'est quand vous voulez mais je préfère
prendre ma punition tout de suite à ce
moment-là professeurs comme ça on en
sera débarrassé
je préfère à l'envi je valais planté sur
un quai moussu elle dit ce qu'elle vient
faire sa promo à la télé tout ça est
parfaitement normal
voici notre cinquième invité gloria
lasso
l'aso bon soir quand est ce que tu as
fait l'amour pour la première pour la
dernière fois le ton accent gloria tu le
fais exprès comme comme jane birkin ou
mousse et naturel il le titre de ton
album c'est bien come back de la semaine
c'est ça ouais ça va non non excusez moi
non pas du tout bienvenue au studio
bonaparte pour hardy matt je tiens à
vous faire part de remarques qui m'ont
été faites sur lesquels je manqué un
petit peu d'enthousiasmé j'aurai une
attitude et un petit peu crispé je serai
pas très souriant
contrairement à nombre de mes collègues
sachez que j'en suis conscient et je
suis prêt à faire tous les efforts
nécessaires pour vous cet aspect c'est
bien de le dire
thierry c'est très bien mais quel effort
pas des trucs re par exemple ça regardez
ça c'est drôle qu'est ce que c'est que
cette chaussure de clown bon désert ah
oui en effet fait roi de la pop
ouais c'est royal tabs envoie le bois il
ya simplement un petit détail qui vous a
échappé le probablement d'envoyer ce que
vous avez devant les pieds ouais ouais
ce qui fait que la chaussure ne se elle
se voit pas elle ne se voit pas alors
pour la drôlerie ont préféré vous
repasserez j'arrive à gérer je ne serai
jamais de chavannes jean marie g un
autre truc ça se voit pour le coup comme
le nez au milieu du nord là ça c'est
marrant et un oui mais il suffit pas de
se déguiser en clown encore faut-il
faire le clown oui oui aventis à poney
c'est qu'il veut pas mourir nos abonnés
1 il veut rester en venant à bout des
oui oui oui un mal léché dit non ça
c'est bizarre oui car ça ça ça ne vous
aurait pas lécher cymbales eshre
oulalala l'audience professeur oui oui
mon nom mon dieu mon dieu je regarde mon
ordinateur et en prennent à la légère
mais cbc et si elles baissent trop il va
falloir que vous le cul y est
son homologue chez les filles et le
chien il va falloir que tu sais morato
c'est moi non non non j'en peux plus je
t'aime et vick avait rien pour toi dans
cette émission par le revolver
non philippe à l'eva temps maintenant je
t'ai dit que rien pour toi dans cette
émission et coûte rien des charges le
jeu ne peut plus assumer car j'ai fait
l'effort un ouh la la
bon je m'en vais a les yeux d'un témoin
important changement
[Musique]
je ne sais pas ce que vous arriverez
vraiment pour les traits de quantité
négligeable
qu'est-ce que vous
j'ai versé à verdun sur vos invités
[Musique]
bonsoir j'ai fini là ça lui jacques soir
son soin bonsoir en merde on en retard
on voulait choper la sortie de scène est
tout autant plus on dit toujours que je
serai pas mal mais invité la junte avait
amené les soupières donc de servir la
soupe en plus c'est pas leur camp qu'est
ce qu'on va faire je prends pas les au
val d'isère on peut aller oui voilà
robert clé alors à boire un coup allez
mourir ça devient avec ta soupe toi
pour basso blind test
[Applaudissements]
et aux platines j'accueille machja série
portier
hu
[Musique]
c'est la maison confie t il
[Applaudissements]
oui est-ce que tu serais venu tout seul
ou quoi alors j'ai même fait beaucoup
mieux tiré
oui nous sommes à l'époque de la
mondialisation d'accord oui l'angleterre
oui
comme entier on me dit plus c'est grâce
à tv5 dans 87 pays
en inde aussi en inde aussi un bon beh
oui et unis
allez bien
oui on est diffusé à la réunion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
corti royal bonsoir mademoiselle julie
sur voilà un garçon qui ne vient jamais
les mains vides
c'est bien philippe lortie mon journal
numérique
on les diffuseurs l'espagne a brillé sur
les deux morts
c'est important carnet d'adressés vous
connaissez le principe du blind test mes
amis tu as eu raison de l'été lunettes
marina parce que c'est le moment pour
écouter
oui c'est le moment important écoutant
vous à ce rebond je veux la terre prête
oui attention et on peut donner un
indice si les gens trouvent que c'est un
spécialiste aly cissé un spécialité a
livré richard cocciante bas il n'y est
pas c'est bien comme exemple à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas ça tombe bien la pression
quelqu'un souffre ici le point bas la
cua et si quelqu'un au souffle la cua ah
oui lallaoui d'achat prévient barzotti
il est il est belge et non là il n'y est
pas faisons jamais d'erreurs dans le
camp jamais alors attention laurent tué
près très près moment l'émir philip wee
guy lepage qui va présenter une émission
au québec qui va s'appeler on en parle
pour lundi
sinon ben
bien taris attention
cet ensemble que man on man pour se
concentrent les enfants monsieur du buzz
attention philippe morceau numéro un je
veux à personne mais j'ai beau qu'avant
la révélation
[Musique]
et je vais te dire un blind test de
corps filles c'est ce qu'ont les mecs
qui sont kamikazes quand ils sont fait
sauter pour l'islam
ils ont droit à ça voilà c'est vrai on a
cinq sont vierges
ouais elles sont bien sûr attiré hawijah
rendre tout à l'heure philippe alors
numéro un donc c'est laurent baffie qui
marque le point comme d'hab à toi
philippe numéro 2 oui
[Musique]
andrea bocelli
pavarotti non
heroes sur wii pour voler
mullan
l'eau
10 degrés j'ai déjà dit quoi
c
[Musique]
ja
alors ça fait le point pour l'équipe de
north ma fille c'est bien ça il s'est
engagé au point pour le kiff que marina
foïs de voir les vidéos fille mais c'est
pas grave tu peux te rattraper marina
papa on a dit uno déjà nous tous nos
chanteurs italiens on les accumule ses
4000 et au fond mon cerveau fou qui
revient on va revenir
attention philippe je me fais plus rien
faire toto cutugno non
[Musique]
ajoutez à fait
m
simon va y aller
ah oui là
m
ici
tita à
rires non
retiré dans les rayons frais des grands
soirs
je crois je crois que c'est albano et
romina power
c'est la fille de tyrone power qui
s'appelle romina power
absolument mais on n'avait pas d'idée de
chercher un non seulement on n'a pas
d'idées dit oh non mais c'est connu ça
non oui c'est connu non me trouvais en
3e mais on a le point va là puisque ça a
été trouvée la banane le point va là
elle ne l'a pas souffler à le point bas
du côté où ça a été trouvé ma ba oui oui
s'adaptant été gérée bon d'accord
c'est elle qui décide c'est logique
c'est moi qui les ai trouvés chez moi je
fais attention continue attention
[Musique]
et
moore
hamon
le tue
on parle trop
non merci
thibault
[Musique]
serge à qui tu donnes le point à bafilo
à marina
m
moi aussi je le rêvais mais à marina tu
vois c'est marrant attention philippe
cau
pourquoi
[Musique]
ma
bientôt cutugno biya c'est comme le 7 à
la boule un moment donné il se sentait
la tension philippe
ben laden
non
3 3 c'est très bagarrer ce soir pour qui
le [ __ ] et populaire un acheteur
philippe il essaye de me demande les
titres étaient avec thomas c'est un
productrice et un fils et moi que c'est
un production suit sur ton à pain de
puch peau ah non mais y en a 1 2 par le
conte est actuaire
tomlin
[Applaudissements]
avi
ils en ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
orlando exige le clip thierry roland
chaque scène jim italienne quand même
oui bah oui alors david harley lien
dirigeant italien s'est faite un
américain alors bas fillon devrait le
demander les dates quand c'est comme ça
trois mois c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
impossible 4 oui madame
à ce qu'a fait françois non j'adore
j'adore
[Musique]
j'adore ça là on l'a pas aussi ni la
solitudine que déjà on continue philippe
corti madame le comté nino rota wood la
ville et ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des filles impérial 6 combats firent pas
pour l'équipe de baffie parce que c'est
vrai que momo et d un peu quand même
oui série 3 pour l'équipe 2 marina foïs
franck dubosc et notre ami thomas
langmann qui a plus de succès avec 2 0
rachid oui il a un prénom mais il a
retrouvé il faut en soi mais n'a aucune
chance d'y arriver on va me la passe
qu'il n'ya pas frédéric françois je peux
dire rappelons la règle thierry
rappelons la règle ils peuvent jouer
aussi ils peuvent jouer trois indiens
des trucs tu as plus important de le
dire
attention corti
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
vial ont agi dressions bravo il est bon
sur ce coup là je les entends bien si
elle connaît ça on a désolé mais enfin
on n'a pas les prénoms l'arsea saskia on
les prive en emballant saint pierre
c'est ce qu'avait mélina mélina jeudi
comme clémence nadia d'accord merci je
te dire merci après voilà d'accord on
continue aujourd'hui pas tension numéro
m
soit
ap
pour la
alors grâce à thomas landman en est à 6
1,6 pour l'équipe de laurent baffie 5
pour l'équipe de marina police alors on
continue
attention corti
[Musique]
olonne l'alabama
bien sûr il faut s'arrêter c'est plus un
jeu c'est de l'humiliation je suis
désormais on s'est passé alors là les
1,6 voilà la fin du père équipe on est à
6 6 ce qui veut dire que l'équipe de
laurent l équipe de marina font match
nul est un petit peu que la france
contre la croatie jeudi dernier un jury
via noyade
ouais heureusement qu'on n'enregistre
pas le jeudi parce qu'on aurait raté ton
était baiser là c'est encore non non
heureusement que nous en direct non ça
c'est la force si bien
magique des reds font rien dire sur les
anglais un nom mais les anglais sont
très bien ils ont battu le record des
italiens pour reboucher le champagne on
a perdu à l'issue du par équipes on est
ainsi 6 et maintenant on passe au chacun
pour sa gueule
ok j'y vais attention n'y a plus d'amis
a plus d'équipé c'est clair donc
maintenant c'est chacun pour soi
corti à toi pour le bon coup risque
[Musique]
au menu
et eux
[Musique]
le mec humble en cellule à paris
mais l'entraîneur
la valeur
le second lui en coller que lui et moi
j'ai façonné à lui pas du mensonge ou
les gens donnent d'ailleurs chez ses
fans il est vraiment été bannis
d'origine italienne essentielle
je crois que le point légal parce que
pagny pas ses impôts en italie donc
attendez attendez catherine attendez
attendez barma dans cette chanson
oui ils voudraient que tu passes la
révélation un petit peu plus longtemps
katrina d'or jusqu'à oui mais moi je
suis fille de me dire ses quatre filles
ouais d'accord c'est la chef place et
l'achète
voilà c'est tout
[Musique]
m
le monde
[Musique]
go
le monde
c'est
[Musique]
j'ai
au regard donc le bon qu aulas a été
remporté par mr achi et voilà il était
même pas vrai mais au début on pince le
super banco c'est très très difficile
ans je pense que peut-être agathe godard
peut trouver parce que c'est notre
époque celle où c'est l'époque on
écoutait des trucs comme ça
vas-y même la radio terre noir et blanc
alors ouais mais est ce qu'il a dit il a
dit bobby solo in a dit
journée
pour
le jeu
[Musique]
nous sommes
m
alors c'est un spécial rebeu parce que
le premier et le deuxième c'est mohamed
vraiment la discrimination en facial ici
les rebeus qui vient de piquer les bons
coups des français je sais bien alors on
passe au méga bourgault major assé y
perdure jusqu'à quand jusqu'en ultra bon
comme et façon tu trouveras pas cherche
pas c'est très très dur
corsi
[Musique]
regarde la terminale en roumanie
pourquoi dit aline italienne il a dit
que claudia cardinale jolie sophia loren
très belle et j'adore je le mets qu'il a
quand même été à il a quand même été au
grand banditisme
pendant des années c'est ce qui vient
donc c'est sophia loren et là je vois
que ça fait quand même deux pour momo à
momo le turbulent qui marque deux points
momo le boxeur qui marque deux points
et là on arrive maintenant à l'ultra
banco la personne qui trouve ça repart
avec toutes les filles et repart et
souple et non franchement je pense que
je vais jouer je vais me défoncer
bien alors attention tout le monde est
bien concentré c'est très très très
difficile moi j'ai du mal
agathe tu dois trouver sa merde et d'or
voilà non pas les seniors
attention aux philippe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
énormes tubes dans les années 60
[Musique]
mais jamie rivers ki-moon et wayne va
vite il a lieu
[Musique]
là tout bâti non merci
je
je viens comme jacques martin le
dimanche
jacques borde a été construit voilà là
laurent tu es un dieu vivant
merci dieu existe il est sur le plateau
ce soir si bon merci mon avis inverse
dont celles issues des chacun pour sa
gueule
rachid un mot modeuses et les plus
difficiles été emportés par la magie
celle ultra méga banques voilà parce que
le monde est injuste même pas 10 et
maintenant on dit maintenant pourquoi
laurent c'est à toi de me dire pourquoi
thierry dans l'ambiance
parce que la vie est injuste laurent un
bal des médias bongo tout ça que c'est
pourri c'est quand même calibre ce
second co ou franchement c'est chacun
pour sa gueule et pourquoi c'est comme
ça tire et parce que la vie est injuste
laurent alors la moins bien fait que
d'habitude le fait de le faire après ça
nous a bloqués chez lui
voilà c'était trop bas elle ferait
d'elle ma pinot grigio jeetah pasqua
dans l'esprit des français
distancé l'amisom
décider s'ils veulent croire épaté faute
à de trop mais qui ça c'est tout mais
belle scène
ces colis toi ils n'ont pas
mais ce conte une histoire dit
stay tuned
monja
les fautes
m
[Musique]
sa bonne foi
on n'était pas là
la solitude
non
[Musique]
mcconnell mondiale ion la photo que rire
ali
qui dit mieux
timide
dgo
celui que
plus tôt
tout ça
par lennon
questions à
les capitalistes
c'est quand
[Musique]
dans l'eau